हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल अ वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबसे पहले मुझे बताइए
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? आई एम
ऑडिबल एवरीवन।
आई एम ऑडिबल एवरीवन।
जल्दी से चैट में यस या नो बताइए। सबको
मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
आई एम ऑडिबल
ओके यस
तो अगेन सबको गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते एंड अगर
कहीं
इंडिया के अलावा और कोई कहीं से है तो
अकॉर्डिंग टू देयर टाइम गुड मॉर्निंग या
गुड नोन एटसे्रा एसे्रा तो कैसे हो आप लोग
कैसे हो आप सब लोग
तो थोड़ा दो मिनट के लिए वेट करते हैं तब
तक के लिए अगर किसी का कोई भी सवाल है कोई
भी क्वेश्चंस है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास या
कोई भी
और भी कुछ क्वेश्चन पूछना है तो अगले दो
मिनट में मैं आंसर करने की कोशिश करूंगा।
तो प्लीज पूछिए दो मिनट का वेट करते हैं
तब तक के लिए। तो अगर किसी का कोई भी सवाल
है तो वह मुझसे पूछ सकता है रिलेटेड टू द
क्लास या कोई भी जनरल सवाल मुझसे आप पूछ
सकते हो रिलेटेड रिलेटेड टू द साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। तो तब तक के लिए फिर एक काम
करते हैं। वेट करते हैं। बाकी और
स्टूडेंट्स को ज्वाइन होने देते हैं।
किसी का कोई सवाल? कोई क्वेश्चन, कोई
डाउट? एनीथिंग एल्स एनीवन वांट टू
शेयर विद मी।
व्हाट इज अपॉर्चुनिटी इन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
या
ओट
आप क्या पूछना चाह रहे हो यह बताओ आपको
एग्जजेक्टली क्या जानना है वह बताओ
फर्निंग के बारे में पूछ रहे हो
तो एक बार मैं कांसेप्ट स्टार्ट कर देता
हूं वैसे लेकिन आपको बता देता हूं जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग है जब भी आप कोई भी रेड टीम
इंगेजमेंट करते हो तो उस टाइम पे कुछ
कंपनीज विद प्रॉपर परमिशंस आपसे सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म करवाती हैं यह जानने
के लिए कि जो मेरे एंप्लई हैं वो
सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड कितने एक्टिव हैं,
कितने इनएक्टिव हैं या क्या वो थ्रेट को
डिटेक्ट कर पाते हैं या नहीं कर पाते
एसेट्रा एसेट्रा इसलिए वह करवाते हैं ताकि
उनको एक रिस्क का पता चल जाए अपनी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से रिलेटेड कि अगर कोई
आउटसाइडर अटैकर अगर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के
थ्रू भी अगर मेरे
कंपनी को ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को थ्रेट देने की
कोशिश करेगा या अटैक करने की कोशिश करेगा
तो कितना रिस्क है यह सारी चीजें
ओके
हां श्योर Linux 35 हम एक काम करने वाले
हैं। माय प्लान इज दैट कि हम जो थ्योरी
पार्ट है YouTube पे कवर करेंगे और फॉर
योर काइंड इंफॉर्मेशन आप लोगों के लिए मैं
प्रैक्टिकल प्लान सोच रहा हूं बट पेड तो
तब तक के लिए मैं आपको टाइम देता हूं कि
अभी कुछ क्लासेस ऐसी होंगी जिसमें हम क्या
करने वाले हैं थ्योरी पार्ट कवर करेंगे।
मैं आपको सारी चीजें बताऊंगा कि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग होती क्या है? कितने टाइप्स
की होती है? एथिकल
या जो लीगल कंसीडरेशंस हैं स्कोप के स्कोप
हो गए या जो सारी चीजें मतलब कि एक बोलते
हैं कि आपको अगर रियल पन टेस्टिंग करनी हो
रियल एंटरप्राइज एनवायरमेंट में करनी हो
किन-किन बातों को आपको ध्यान में रखना है
कैसे आपको चीजें करनी है सारी चीजें हम
यहां पर YouTube पे डिस्कस करेंगे लेकिन
जब जहांजहां पर मतलब प्रैक्टिकल्स की बात
आएगी खास करके सोशल इंजीनियरिंग क्योंकि
अकॉर्डिंग टू द जो YouTube पॉलिसी के
अगेंस्ट जा सकता है तो उसको हम यहां पर
अवॉइड करेंगे।
और तब तक के लिए आप लोग सोच लीजिए कि अगर
आपके पास पैसे नहीं है तो प्लीज मैनेज और
आप लोगों से मैं एक खुद से ही पूछ रहा हूं
कि कल की क्लास से पहले या नेक्स्ट जो भी
क्लास होगी उससे पहले आप सोच लीजिए कि
कितने अमाउंट में आप कंफर्टेबल हो उस
प्रैक्टिकल को देखने के लिए उतना ही आप
लोगों के लिए हम क्या करेंगे प्राइस
रखेंगे पैसे डिसाइड कर लेंगे ताकि आप
लोगों को एक लाइव प्रैक्टिकल देखने को मिल
सके। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के ऊपर पेड इसलिए
रखेंगे बिकॉज़ यह अगेंस्ट द YouTube
पॉलिसीज या कहीं पर भी हम ओपन सोर्स नहीं
दिखा सकते। दैट इज व्हाई। तो उसके लिए
आपको जल्दी से बता दिया जाएगा। जब भी होगा
जब भी मैं आपको हिंट दे दूंगा हम हम उसके
रिलेटेड आपसे रजिस्ट्रेशन ले लेंगे। बट
अभी के लिए यह प्लान है। इन प्रोग्रेस है।
आई एम नॉट श्योरिटी बट आई विल ट्राई माय
100%। ओके।
तो किसी के कोई सवाल नहीं है ना तो क्लास
को स्टार्ट करें फिर अभी
बस आप लोगों से एक ही रिक्वेस्ट रहेगी
मेरी जितना हो सके क्लास को शेयर कीजिए
ओके लोगों के साथ इसको शेयर करने की कोशिश
करो आप बस मेरी रिक्वेस्ट यह रहेगी कंटेंट
की गारंटी मेरी है और यह वह कंटेंट है जो
YouTube पे एक साथ नहीं मिलेगा एक क्लास
के फॉर्म में और बिल्कुल स्टेप बाय स्टेप
डिटेल्स में जहां तक मुझे मुझे नॉलेज है
जहां तक मुझे पता है शायद YouTube पे नहीं
होगा वो बिकॉज़ सब अवॉइड करते हैं। ये एक
पेड क्लास एक प्रीमियम क्लासेस का जो
कंटेंट है मैं आपको यहां पर फ्री में
पढ़ाने जा रहा हूं। ओके? तो चलिए फिर
क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं। एवरीवन रेडी?
एवरीवन रेडी? अभी भी स्टूडेंट्स नहीं आ
रहे। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। हम पढ़ाएंगे।
आप जितने भी हैं सब लोग रेडी हो?
चलिए फिर लेट्स गो टू आवर पीपीटीस। नाउ।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलो फिर लेट्स स्टार्ट आवर टॉपिक। आप सब
लोग रेडी हो तो
नाउ
देखो आज की क्लास में हम साइबर सिक्योरिटी
का एक बहुत ही इंपॉर्टेंट बहुत ही
क्रिटिकल या हाईली प्रैक्टिकल जो
इंप्लीमेंटेड है जो हाईली प्रैक्टिकल हर
एक साइबर अटैक में परफॉर्म किया जाता है
वो चैप्टर हम शुरू करने जा रहे हैं किसके
अंदर एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के
अंदर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। ओके? जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का जो टॉपिक है उसको हम
स्टार्ट करने जा रहे हैं आज की क्लास से।
तो पिछले लेक्चर्स में थोड़ा सा बता देता
हूं कि हमने क्या-क्या पढ़ा है। क्लास 60,
क्लास 61 और क्लास 62 क्लासेस में हमने
क्या-क्या पढ़ा है कि हमने पढ़ा था कि
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स क्या होते हैं? उनके
अलग-अलग वेक्टर्स कैसे काम करते हैं?
कौन-कौन से टाइप्स के अटैक वेक्टर्स
अवेलेबल्स हैं? और उनके जनरल जो
मेथोडोलॉजी थी, जो जनरल टेक्निक्स हैं, वो
क्या-क्या है? और जनरल टेक्निक्स कौन सी
जनरल टेक्निक्स का वो यूज करते हैं? यह
सारी चीजों को हमने प्रीवियस क्लास में
पढ़ा था। आई होप सबको इस चीज के बारे में
पता होगा। अगर कोई नया स्टूडेंट है आज
फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में आया है तो प्लीज
क्लास 61 से ले क्लास 62
तक पढ़ लीजिए। आप लोगों को पूरा पता चल
जाएगा। जस्ट गिव मी 1 मिनट गाइस।
ओके लेट्स स्टार्ट आवर टॉपिक नाउ तो चलिए
चलते हैं फिर तो आज की क्लासेस में आपको
पहले बता देता हूं मैं कुछ अ पोस्टर्स हैं
कुछ अ
आपको प्रैक्टिकली शो करने के लिए कि आपको
मतलब विजुअलाइज करवाने के लिए आपको क्लास
बोरिंग ना लगे। इसलिए मैंने कुछ पोस्टर्स
डिज़ाइन करवाए हैं अकॉर्डिंग टू माय कंटेंट
अह विथ द हेल्प ऑफ़ एआई ताकि आपको
कंफर्टेबिलिटी मिले। आपको समझ में आए
चीजें। तो ऐसे बहुत सारे पोस्टर्स आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे। तो वो आप लोगों के लिए
ही ताकि आप लोगों को नॉलेज गेन मिले। तो
चलिए स्टार्ट करते हैं। देखो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी इज नॉट ओनली अबाउट राइटिंग
कोड, ब्रेकिंग फायर वाल्स, रनिंग टर्मिनल
कमांड्स, एक्सप्लइटिंग टेक्निकल
वनरेबिलिटीज।
ए वेरी लार्ज पार्ट ऑफ हैकिंग इज बेस्ड ऑन
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी।
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी। देखिए
अगर आपको लगता है कि हैकिंग सिर्फ कोड
लिखना फायर वॉल ब्रेक करना या टर्मिनल पर
कमांड चलाने तक लिमिट है तो आप गलत हैं।
क्योंकि हैकिंग का एक बहुत बड़ा हिस्सा
ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी पर चलता है। जो ह्यूमन
साइकोलॉजी है उसके ऊपर काम करता है। ए
कॉमन मिसकंसेप्शन अमोंग बिगिनर्स इज दैट
हैकिंग एक्सक्लूसिवली इनवॉल्व टारगेटिंग
मशीन सर्वर्स नेटवर्क एप्लीकेशनेशंस।
जितने भी बिगिनर्स होते हैं, ओके? जितने
भी जो नए-नए पेन टेस्टिंग करते हैं, जितने
भी स्टूडेंट्स, सब में एक एक कॉमन
मिसकंसेप्शन होता है कि हैकिंग क्या होता
है कि जो मशीनंस है चाहे Linux है, चाहे
फिर आपका Windows है उनको टारगेट करना,
सर्वर्स को टारगेट करना, नेटवर्क को
टारगेट करना या एप्लीकेशनेशंस को टारगेट
करना। यह उनके दिमाग में एक मिसकंसेप्शन
होता है। इस मिसकंसेप्शन को निकाल दीजिए।
हाउएवर द ट्रुथ इज दैट अटैकर्स
फ्रीक्वेंटली डू नॉट इंटिमेट देयर असॉल्ट
ऑन टेक्नोलॉजी इटसेल्फ। हालांकि क्या होता
है कि सच्चाई यह है कि जो अटैकर्स होते
हैं वो फ्रीक्वेंटली क्या करते हैं?
फ्रीक्वेंटली टेक्नोलॉजी को अटैक नहीं
करते। अगर कोई भी बड़ा साइबर अटैक करना तो
फ्रीक्वेंटली कभी भी टेक्नोलॉजी को
डायरेक्ट अटैक नहीं करते। उसकी बजाय क्या
करते हैं? दे ऑफन फोकस ऑन द इंडिविजुअल्स
हु यूटिलाइज़ दैट टेक्नोलॉजी। वो क्या
करते हैं कि उस इंडिविजुअल इंडिविजुअल में
कौन आता है? आप मैं या जो भी कंपनी के
एंप्लाइज होते हैं या जो भी कंपनी के अंदर
इंसान काम करते हैं, ह्यूमन बीइंग काम
करते हैं जो उस टेक्नोलॉजी को यूटिलाइज
करते हैं वो उनके ऊपर फोकस करते हैं। वो
क्या करते हैं? उनके ऊपर फोकस करते हैं।
इसलिए
अब हमारा जो पूरा फोकस रहेगा वो हमारा
पूरा फोकस करने वाले हैं हम किसके ऊपर? एक
ऐसे डोमेन के ऊपर जिसे हम कहते हैं सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। अब हम अपना पूरा फोकस किसके
ऊपर करने वाले हैं? ऐसे डोमेन के ऊपर
जिसको हम बोलते हैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। आप
में से कुछ लोगों को इसके बारे में पहले
से थोड़ा बहुत पता होगा। कुछ के दिमाग में
इसके रिलेटेड कुछ मिसकंसेप्शनंस होंगे और
कुछ के लिए यह बिल्कुल नया होगा। तो आप
चाहे आपको पहले से पता हो चाहे आपके दिमाग
में उसके लिए मिसकंसेप्शंस हो चाहे फिर आप
बिल्कुल नए हो। तीनों के लिए मैं क्या
करने वाला हूं? बिल्कुल शुरू से बिल्कुल
स्क्रैच से इसको क्या करने वाला हूं?
समझाने वाला हूं। स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं
हम। तो सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं? एक
कंपैरिजन करते हैं। किसका? एथिकल हैकिंग
वर्सेस क्रिमिनल माइंडसेट के साथ। तो जस्ट
एक मिनट गाइस मैं एक पेन ले लेता हूं।
ये रहा। कुछ
नाउ कंपेयर करने वाले हैं एथिकल हैकिंग
वर्सेस क्रिमिनल माइंड सेट। देखो जो हमारा
कोर्स है ना जो भी हमारा अभी कोर्स चल रहा
है किस कौन सा हमारा एक्सटर्न पे टेस्टिंग
का डीईएचई का डेफोनस एथिकल हैकर
एसेंशियल्स इसमें हम अभी कौन से टॉपिक
चैप्टर कवर कर रहे हैं हम सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग इस कोर्स में हम क्या करने
वाले हैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग को पेंटेस्टर
के पर्सेक्टिव से सीखने वाले हैं किसके
पर्सपेक्टिव से हम पेंटेस्टर के
पर्सपेक्टिव से सीखने वाले हैं ना कि किसी
क्रिमिनल माइंड के मतलब हम क्या करने हैं
वो सारे सारे टेक्निक्स का यूज करेंगे वो
सेम टेक्निक टेिक्स या जो भी टेक्नोलॉजी
जो भी टूल्स हैं वो सारे टेक्नोलॉजी और
टेिक्स को कॉपी करेंगे जो एक मशियस एक जो
मिलेशियस एडवाइज़री जो एडवाइज़री होते हैं
या जो भी बैड गाय होते हैं जो जो साइबर
क्रिमिनल्स होते हैं या जो क्रिमिनल
माइंडसेट के जो अह अटैकर्स होते हैं वो
जिन-जिन मूव्स जिनजिन अह टेक का या
जिन-जिन टैक्टिक्स का यूज़ करते हैं वो
सारे के सारे चीज हम क्या करने वाले हैं
अपने पेन टेस्टिंग में सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
की पेन टेस्टिंग में यूज करने वाले हैं।
बट हमारा मोटिव क्या रहेगा? हमारा मोटिव
रहेगा एथिकल। हमारा मोटिव क्या होगा?
एथिकल होगा। हमारा मोटिव होगा एथिकल हैकर
की तरह ना कि एक क्रिमिनल अटैक माइंडसेट
की तरह। अब क्रिमिनल माइंडसेट का मतलब
क्या है मेरा? क्रिमिनल माइंडसेट का मतलब
क्या है? कि ना तो वो कोई परमिशन लेते और
अन ऑथराइज एक्सेस करते हैं। डाटा को
चुराते हैं, फाइनेंसियल गेन करते हैं।
मतलब फाइनेंसियल फ्रॉड करते हैं।
मैनपुलेशनंस करते हैं डाटा के साथ। उसके
बाद जो भी कंपनी है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन उसके साथ
क्या डैमेज जो उसकी रेपुटेशन उसको डैमेज
करने की कोशिश करते हैं। और सबसे बड़ी बात
क्या है कि जो भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है उस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को हार्म पहुंचाते हैं।
हार्म का मतलब उसको नुकसान पहुंचाते हैं।
उसकी रेपुटेशन बिल्कुल खत्म कर देते हैं।
या मतलब सीधा-सीधा कह सकते हैं जो
क्रिमिनल माइंडसेट होते हैं वो
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के अगेंस्ट काम करते हैं
बेसिकली। और हम क्या करने वाले हैं? हम एज
ए एथिकल हैकर एज ए पेंटेस्टस। हम जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग को यूज करेंगे हम यूज करेंगे
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर जो भी सिक्योरिटी
वीकनेसेस हैं ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर जो
सिक्योरिटी वीकनेसेस हैं उसको फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए उसको फाइंड आउट करके फिक्स
करेंगे ठीक है उसके पहले जो सिक्योरिटी
वीकनेस उसको फाइंड आउट और फिक्स करेंगे और
सबसे बड़ी बात क्या हमारे पास इस अटैक को
परफॉर्म करने के के लिए हमारे पास क्या
होता है रिटर्न परमिशन होती है जो भी अटैक
है इसको परफॉर्म करने के लिए हमारे पास
रिटर्न परमिशंस होते हैं। हमारे पास एक
प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन होता है। लीगल एग्रीमेंट
साइन करते हैं हम क्लाइंट के साथ। हमारे
पास स्कोप डिफाइंड होता है। रूल्स ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट ये सारी चीजें हम उसमें फॉलो
करते हैं। और जो भी सिक्योरिटी
इंप्रूवमेंट है। अगर हमने पेन टेस्टिंग की
हमने सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की और उसके जो
रिपोर्ट्स हैं जब वो रिपोर्ट्स में हम सब
कुछ लिखते हैं कि आप में यह एक
वनेरेबिलिटी थी। हमने यह टेस्ट परफॉर्म
किया था या हम फिशिंग की थी, विसिंग की
थी, व्हाटएवर टेक्निक वी विल फॉलो और हमें
यह लूप होल मिले तो आपको इस पे काम करना
चाहिए। इस पे पॉलिसी बनानी चाहिए या इस पे
ये सॉल्यूशन लगा सकते हो या ये ट्रेनिंग
आपको इंक्लूड करनी चाहिए। ये सारी चीजें
हम क्या करते हैं? हम क्लाइंट को जिसके के
लिए हम पेन टेस्टिंग करें वो सारी चीजें
हम बताते हैं। तो इसलिए हम हम मैंने आपको
क्या बताया कि हम क्या सीखने वाले हैं? हम
एज ए एथिकल हैकर एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स हम क्या
करेंगे पेंटेस्टिंग पर्सपेक्टिव से सोशल
जो इंजीनियरिंग है सोशल एसओसी जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग की बात कर रहा हूं एसओसी वो
दूसरे वाला नहीं एज ए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग हम
क्या करेंगे पटेस्टिंग पर्सपेक्टिव से
डिस्कस करेंगे सब कुछ और पेंटेस्टिंग
पर्सेक्टिव से जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कैसे
परफॉर्म की जाती है वो हम परफॉर्म करेंगे
रेदर देन एक क्रिमिनल माइंडसेट के साथ यह
चीज क्लियर है सबको
यह चीज सबको क्लियर है? एवरीथिंग यह चीज
समझ में आ गया कि हम एक्चुअल में क्या चीज
सीखने वाले हैं। सबको मजा आ रहा है? सबको
चीजें क्लियर दिखाई दे रही है?
समझ में आ गया सबको?
जल्दी से चैट में बताओ।
हां। हां अमन पटेल इसकी कुछ चीजें हम
YouTube पे कवर करेंगे और जो इसका हाइली
प्रैक्टिकल्स है आई विल ट्राई ये कवर हो
जाए।
चलिए नेक्स्ट व्हाट इज सोशल इंजीनियरिंग?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग होता क्या है? भैया सबसे
पहले हम क्या करते हैं? एक फॉर्मल या कोई
एक प्रिसाइज डेफिनेशन है। उसको समझते हैं
रिगार्डिंग टू सोशल इंजीनियरिंग।
विद इन द रेलम ऑफ पेन टेस्टिंग एंड रेड
टीम रेड टीमिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग रेफर्ड
टू ए स्ट्रेटजी एंप्लॉयड बाय एन अटैकर और
अनऑथराइज्ड टेस्टर टू इन्फ्लुएंस
मैनपुलेट और डिसीव एंप्लाइजज़ और
इंडिविजुअल्स
डिसीव एंप्लाइजज़ और इंडिविजुअल्स द गोल इज
टू इनकरेज देम टू डिस्क्लोज़ सेंसिटिव
इनेशन टेक स्पेसिफिक एक्शनंस एंड ग्रांट
एक्सेस टू सिस्टम
डाटा एंड फिजिकल लोकेशनेशंस।
पेन टेस्टिंग और रेड टीमिंग के
कॉन्टेक्स्ट में सोशल इंजीनियरिंग एक ऐसी
टेक्निक है जहां हम किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के एंप्लाइज या
इंडिविजुअल्स को मैनपुलेट करते हैं। और
क्यों मैनपुलेट करते हैं? ताकि हम उनसे
उनकी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के बारे में सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस निकाल सके। उनके सिस्टम्स
की इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सके या जो फिजिकल
लोकेशनेशंस होती है उसका अन ऑथराइज्ड
एक्सेस ले सकें। इसलिए हम क्या करते हैं?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज करते हैं। टू पुट
इट सिंपली सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इनवॉल्व्स
लेवरेजिंग ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी टू एक्सप्लइट
वनेरेबिलिटीज रेदर देन टारगेटिंग टेक्निकल
वीकनेसेस डायरेक्टली। इसका मतलब यह है कि
अगर सिंपल शब्दों में बात करें तो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का मतलब है कि हम क्या करते
हैं कि ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी का यूज करते हैं
वनेबिलिटीज को फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
एक्सप्लइट करने के लिए रेदर देन टेक्निकली
वीकनेसेस को ढूंढने के लिए। मतलब हम क्या
करते हैं? टेक्निकल वनेबिलिटीज ढूंढने की
बजाय हम ह्यूमन वनेबिलिटीज का फायदा उठाते
हैं या ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी का यूज करते हैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग जैसे अटैक को परफॉर्म
करने के लिए। उसे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करने के
लिए ताकि हम अपना अटैक बेहतरीन तरीके से
प्रिपेयर कर सकें।
ओके
फाइनेंस को क्या कहने की कोशिश कर रहे हो
आप? क्या बोल रहे हो आप?
आपका सवाल समझा नहीं।
क्या कुछ समझ में नहीं आ रहा या कुछ टोन
में प्रॉब्लम है मेरी? एवरीथिंग इज
क्लियर? सबको समझ में आ रहा है ना?
ओके ओके ओके तो नाउ कोर मैकेनिज्म बिहाइंड
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग तो हम बात करते हैं कि
जो ये अटैक है जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक
है पूरी तरह से तीन चीजों पर डिपेंड करता
है। पहली तो ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी दूसरा
ट्रस्ट तीसरा ह्यूमन मलबिलिटीज। जो तीन
चीज है ना ये सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इन तीन
चीजों पर बहुत डिपेंड करता है। चौथी चीज
पे डिपेंड करता ही नहीं। तो कभी भी आपको
पूछे अगर कोई पूछता है कि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग सबसे ज्यादा किन तीन एरियाज
पर डिपेंड करता है? तो पहला एरिया कौन सा
है? वो है आपका ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी। दूसरा
है आपका ट्रस्ट। तीसरा आपका ह्यूमन
वनेरेबिलिटीज। क्योंकि
क्योंकि मैं आपको बताता हूं। क्योंकि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग बेसिकली एक ऐसी टेक्निक है
जहां हम ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी का यूज करके
क्या करते हैं? लोगों को इनफ्लुएंस करने
की कोशिश करते हैं।
ठीक है? मेरा हम उसे क्या है? इन्फ्लुएंस
करने की कोशिश करते हैं। प्लीज ऐसा कोई
क्वेश्चन मत पूछो कि जो अभी मैं आपकी तरफ
मेरा ध्यान जाए क्योंकि मैं अभी चैट पढ़ता
हूं और आपके जो क्वेश्चंस मैं देखता हूं
ना तो मैं अपना जो कांसेप्ट है उससे थोड़ा
सा इधर-उधर हो जा रहा हूं। तो प्लीज आई
रिक्वेस्ट आपको ऐसा कोई पर्सनल क्वेश्चंस
पूछना है कोई करियर से रिलेटेड तो प्लीज
आस्क यू इन द एंड ऑफ़ द सेशन। ये मेरी
रिक्वेस्ट है क्योंकि जो कंटेंट मैं आपके
लिए रेडी करके लाया हूं उसमें फिर क्या है
डिस्टरबेंस होता है। जैसे कि अभी मैं आपका
क्वेश्चन देखा तो थोड़ा डिस्टरबेंस होगा
कि आपको क्या बोल रहा था और अभी मैं ध्यान
दे रहा हूं। तो मैं आपको अगेन आई एम रिपीट
करता हूं। तो देखिए ये जो सोशल इंजीनियर
अटैक है ये पूरी तरीके से तीन चीजों पर
डिपेंड करता है। कौन सा? ह्यूमन
साइकोलॉजी, ट्रस्ट एंड ह्यूमन एबिलिटी।
मतलब क्या है? मतलब यह है कि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग क्या है? एक ऐसी अटैक टेक्निक
है जहां पर हम क्या करते हैं? जो ह्यूमन
साइकोलॉजी है उसका यूज़ करके टारगेट को
इन्फ्लुएंस करते हैं। हम क्या करते हैं?
टारगेट को इन्फ्लुएंस करते हैं। एंड ईच
इंडिविजुअल पोज़े पोज़ेसिस इमोशंस, हैबिट,
रूटंस, फिय्स, अजमशंस एंड इंस्ट्रक्टिव
रिएक्शन। मतलब दुनिया में ऐसा कोई भी
इंसान नहीं है ना ही होगा कि जिसके पास
कोई इमोशन ना हो। उसकी आदतें ना हो, उसका
कोई रूटीन ना हो, उसको किसी चीज का डर ना
हो या वो अज्यूम नहीं करता हो, इमेजिनेशन
नहीं करता हो या उसके पास वो रिएक्शन ना
करें। यह जो भी आदतें हैं यह बहुत ही कॉमन
आदतें हैं किसी भी इंसान की और दुनिया में
ऐसा कोई भी इंसान नहीं है जिसमें ये ये जो
आदतें नहीं हो इसीलिए अटैकर्स क्या करते
हैं जो ये आदतें हैं आपकी इमोशंस आपकी
हैबिट्स आपका रूटीनंस आपका डर है या आप जो
कैसे आपकी अजम अजमशन है कैसी आपकी थिंकिंग
है कैसे आप रिएक्ट करते हो इन सारी चीजों
को क्या करते हैं वे कलेक्ट करते हैं और
इन सारी चीजों को कलेक्ट करके एक अटैकर
आपकी ह्यूमन कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स को क्या
करता है
ह्यूमन कैरेक्टरिस्ट को क्या करता है? वह
एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश करता है। नाउ अभी
हम आते हैं गोल पर। द गोल ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। कि अभी गोल क्या है सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का गोल
क्या है? देखो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का गोल है
कि टारगेट कोई स्पेसिफिक एक्शन परफॉर्म
करें। जैसे किसी मिलिशियस लिंक पर क्लिक
करें या फिर कोई मिलिशियस फाइल को ओपन
करें या फिर
कोई क्यूआर कोड को स्कैन करें या कोई
लॉगिन रिक्वेस्ट है या उसका जो मल्टीफैक्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन उसको अप्रूव करें। आपको ओटीपी
दे या फिर आपके जो फेक वेबसाइट है उसको
क्या करें? विजिट करें।
पहला टारगेट तो यह है कि या तो कोई लिंक
पर क्लिक कर दे, कोई फाइल डाउनलोड कर ले,
क्यूआर कोड स्कैन कर दे या फिर आपका जो
लॉगिन रिक्वेस्ट है उसको एक्सेप्ट कर ले
या फिर आपकी जो फेक वेबसाइट है उस पे
विजिट करवा ले। किससे? टारगेट से। पहला तो
काम क्या है? दूसरा क्या है? या फिर या
दूसरा गोल क्या है? या फिर वो कोई
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन लीक कर दे। जैसे
यूजरनेम है, पासवर्ड है, ईमेल एड्रेस है,
फोन नंबर्स है या आपके एंप्लई की डिटेल्स
हो गई या इंटरनल सिस्टम्स की कोई डिटेल्स
हो गई। जैसे टूल का नाम हो गया,
प्लेटफार्म का नाम हो गया या जो सिस्टम्स
है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर कौन से यूज़ हो
रहे हैं उसके बारे में कोई या बातों बातों
में कोई प्रोजेक्ट का नाम डिस्कस
डिस्क्लोज़ कर दे या कंपनी कैसे प्रोसेस
करती है? कोई इंटरनल इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर होगी
या उसका वर्क फ्लो हो गया या कोई पॉलिसीज
की हिंट दे दे। मतलब कुछ ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन
लीक कर दे जो काफी सेंसिटिव हो। रिलेटेड
टू द रिलेटेड टू द कंपनी या ऑर्गेनाइजेशन।
तो ये सबको समझ में आ रहा है?
मजा आ रहा है सबको? स्लाइड अच्छे लग रहे
हैं सबको? तो ये है हमारा सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का गोल कि या तो कोई
स्पेसिफिक एक्शन परफॉर्म कर दें या फिर
क्या करें? कोई सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन लीक
कर दें। यूजर नेम, पासवर्ड, ईमेल एड्रेस,
फोन नंबर्स, एंप्लॉय डिटेल्स या इंटरनल
सिस्टम, प्रोजेक्ट नेम। ऐसे बहुत सारे
पोस्टर्स हैं। ऐसे बहुत सारी इमेजज़ मैंने
आप लोगों के लिए ऐड की है ताकि आप मतलब कि
एक तो आपके सामने विजुअल रहे और साथ में
आप मेरे को सुनते रहो तो आप लोगों को
चीजें क्लेरिटी मिल जाए। मजा आ रहा है?
सबको क्लेरिटी मिल रही है? चीजों की?
अब यह जो अटैक्स होते हैं ना आपके सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग वाले यह अटैक्स आपके जो भी
साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंडस्ट्री है या जो भी
हैकर कम्युनिटी है उसमें बहुत बड़ा मेजर
रोल प्ले करते हैं। अगर कभी भी आपने ध्यान
से देखा होगा कभी भी ध्यान से कुछ चीजें
नोटिस की होंगी तो इस तरह का बिहेवियर
क्या है ना आपको अपनी नॉर्मल लाइफ में भी
देखने को मिलेगा आपको क्या करेगा नॉर्मल
लाइफ में भी देखने को मिलेगा तो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग डेली लाइफ जैसे कोई भी एक
सेल्समैन है
वह भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग यूज करता है।
बच्चे पेरेंट्स से कुछ भी काम करवाने के
लिए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज करते हैं। या
पेरेंट्स बच्चे से कुछ काम करवाना डराने
धमकाने के लिए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़
करते हैं। या जो स्कैमर्स हैं स्क
स्कैमर्स भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़ करते
हैं। मतलब हमारी जो डेली लाइफ्स है उसमें
भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग बहुत ज्यादा यूज़ होती
है। जाने या अनजाने में हर कोई सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़ करता ही करता है। बट
हमें पता नहीं कि वह टर्म क्या थी। वह
हमें पता नहीं। तो सबसे पहले हम डिस्कस
करते हैं सेल्स ड्यूरिंग सेल्स एंड
मार्केटिंग। मतलब एक सेल्समैन जब एक
सेल्समैन आपको कॉल करता है। कोई भी आपका
सेल्समैन जैसे एक यह सेल्समैन है और आपको
कॉल किया जब वो आपको कॉल करता है और कॉल
करने के बाद यह सबके साथ होता है। यू आर
नॉट द फर्स्ट वन। ना मैं पहला बंदा था ना
आप लोग पहले होगे कि जब भी कोई एक सेल्स
पर्सन या कोई भी सेल्समैन आपको कॉल करता
है और आपको आपकी प्रॉब्लम का सॉल्यूशन पिच
करता है क्योंकि उसको पता होगा जब आपको
कॉल करेगा तो आपकी कोई ना कोई प्रॉब्लम्स
प्रॉब्लम्स आप रही होगी और उसी प्रॉब्लम
का सॉल्यूशन आपको पिच करेगा तो उस उस टाइम
वो क्या करता है वो आपको इन्फ्लुएंस करने
की कोशिश कर रहा होता है मतलब आपकी
प्रॉब्लम है आपकी प्रॉब्लम होगी कोई भी पी
ठीक है इस प्रॉब्लम का सोलशन वो लेके
आएगा। इसका क्या लेके आएगा? सॉल्यूशन लेके
आएगा। और सॉल्यूशन को पिच करेगा आपके
सामने। जब सॉल्यूशन को पिच करेगा वो आपको
क्या करने की कोशिश कर रहा है? आपको
इन्फ्लुएंस करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। ताकि
आप उसकी बात को मान लो। अब बात ऐसी है कि
अगर प्रॉब्लम का सॉल्यूशन आपको पसंद आया।
उसमें अच्छी टेक्निक है प्रीक्स्ट करने
की, पिच करने की और आपको सशन पसंद आया तो
मतलब वो सक्सेस हो गया। अदरवाइज फिर
नेक्स्ट टारगेट। अदरवाइज़ फिर नेक्स्ट
टारगेट। अगली बात करते हैं। जैसे कि यह है
अभी
साइकोलॉजिकल टैिक्स दिन में हर किसी के
साथ हुई होगी। हमारे साथ भी होती है। आप
लोगों के साथ भी होती है और होती ही रहेगी
ये चीज। कोई भी एक स्टूडेंट क्या करता है?
कोई भी एक बच्चा है अपने पेरेंट्स से अगर
उसको किसी भी चीज से रिलेटेड परमिशन
मांगनी है। अगर उसको कोई परमिशन ग्रांट
करवानी है, कहीं पर जाना है या कुछ अपने
माता-पिता से उनको चाहिए तो दे सिंपली
कंपैरिजन कर देते हैं। बोलते हैं कि मॉम
एंड डैड कि सभी बच्चे ऐसा कर रहे हैं या
सभी बच्चों के पास यह चीज है या सभी बच्चे
वहां पर जा रहे हैं। मतलब या तो आपको कोई
अथॉरिटी चाहिए या आपको कोई ऐसी चीज चाहिए
जो सबके पास है। तो मतलब आपको जब भी अपने
पेरेंट्स से कुछ भी चाहिए होता है तो आप
क्या करते हो? सोशल प्रेशर का यूज़ करते
हो। किसका यूज़ करते हो आप? सोशल प्रेशर का
आप यूज़ करते हो। आप सोशल प्रेशर का यूज़
करते हो। एक मिनट।
आप क्या करते हो? एक सोशल प्रेशर का यूज़
करते हो। यहां लिख भी नहीं पाऊंगा मैं।
एक सोशल प्रेशर का यूज़ करते हो। जिसको हम
क्या बोल सकते हैं? पीियर प्रेशर भी बोल
सकते हैं। सोशल प्रेशर मतलब कंपैरिजन
करेंगे। मतलब कोई अथॉरिटी गेन करने के
लिए। तो ये आप डेली बेसिस में आप हमेशा ये
टेक्निक लगाते हैं। जब भी हम स्कूल डेज
में रहते हैं, कोरियर डेज में रहते हैं।
हमें पैसे चाहिए होते हैं। कहीं पर घूमना
होता है। अथॉरिटी गेन करनी पड़ते हैं। हम
क्या करते हैं? सोशल प्रेशर को यूज़ करते
हैं। सेम अब पेरेंट्स भी तो कम नहीं है
ना। आप बच्चे हो तो पेरेंट्स भी हैं।
पेरेंट्स क्या करते हैं? पेरेंट्स भी क्या
करते हैं? आपको डराने के लिए या आपकी
सेफ्टी के लिए, आपकी सिक्योरिटी के लिए या
आप कोई गलत काम ना करो या फिर आप किसी गलत
रास्ते पर ना जाए या फिर आपकी एज के
अकॉर्डिंग उनको लगता है कि आप कुछ गलत
करने वाले हैं या आप गलत कर सकते हो या
गलत कर रहे हो तो आपको डराने के लिए
धमकाने के लिए वह काम रुकवाने के लिए मतलब
आपके प्रिवेंशन के लिए या आपके प्रोटेक्शन
के लिए वो वो भी क्या करते हैं?
वह भी आपके लिए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक
का ही यूज करते हैं या इस साइकोलॉजिकल
टेक्निक का ही यूज करते हैं। चाहे आपको
क्या करेंगे? डरा देंगे कि ऐसा हो गया तो
ऐसा हो जाएगा या किसी
अच्छे बच्चे जो इससे बेहतरीन अच्छा बच्चा
होगा उसके साथ कंपैरिजन करेंगे कि उसने
ऐसा-सा किया तुम भी ऐसा कर सकते हो। मतलब
या तो मोटिवेशन हो सकता है या फियर हो कुछ
भी हो पेरेंट्स भी उसी चीज को यूज करते
हैं। जैसे
जैसा एक बच्चा अपने पेरेंट्स के साथ कुछ
भी चीजें मनवाने के लिए करता है। सेम
पेरेंट्स भी क्या करते हैं? उस उससे वह
काम मनवाने के लिए या उसको प्रोटेक्शन
देने के लिए उसको बचाने के लिए कुछ भी हो
सकता है। वो भी क्या करते हैं?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का ही यूज़ करते हैं। या
हम बोल सकते हैं एक्चुअल बोले तो
साइकोलॉजिकल टैक्टिक बोल सकते हैं इसको।
अब यह कौन-कौन से टैिक्स होते हैं? वह मे
बी नेक्स्ट टू नेक्स्ट क्लास में पढ़े या
कल वाले क्लास में मुश्किल है कल वाले
क्लास में लेकिन हो सकता है कि नेक्स्ट टू
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम उन कुछ सोशल टेिक्स
होती हैं उनके बारे में डिस्कशन करें।
नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं स्कैमर्स के
बारे में। स्कैमर्स भी क्या करते हैं
भैया? स्कैमर्स भी आपके लिए सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़ करते हैं। जैसे सबने
सुना होगा जैसे आपके पास कॉल आ गया। कोई
फेक माइक्रोसॉफ्ट कॉल आ गया कि
विंडो डिफेंडर अलर्ट है। सिस्टम को
अपग्रेड कर लीजिए। आपका सिस्टम रिस्क में
है तो प्लीज नीचे लिंक दिया है या फोन
नंबर है या इस पर आप क्लिक कर दीजिए या
वेबसाइट पर जाइए और अपग्रेड कर लीजिए। या
फिर बैंक अकाउंट से आप क्या करते हो आप?
बैंक अकाउंट सस्पेंशन का कोई टैक्स ईमेल आ
गया कि आपका अकाउंट सस्पेंड कर दिया गया
है। बिकॉज़ सिक्योरिटी अपग्रेड नहीं था। यह
इशू था ये उसे था। तो यह भी क्या है? एक
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग है। नाइजीरियन प्रिंस के
बारे में किसने सुना है?
नाइजीरियन प्रिंस ईमेल स्कैम के बारे में
किसी ने सुना है? जैसे यहां पिक्चर में
दिखाई दे रहा है आपको नाइजीरियन प्रिंस
ईमेल स्कैम के बारे में किसी ने सुना है।
अगर आप लोग मोबाइल यूज़ करते हो ड्यूरिंग
क्लासेस तो आपको पता है कि YouTube की जो
स्क्रीन है उसको आप ज़ूम कर सकते हो। ज़ूम
करके उस पर्टिकुलर एरिया को देख सकते हो
अगर नहीं दिखा है। ठीक है? नाइजीरियन
प्रिंस एक आप Google करना तो Google पे
आपको मिल जाएगा। नाइजीरियन प्रिंस बहुत
फेमस थे। बहुत स्कैम में इन्वॉल्व था। ठीक
है? तो उसकी ईमेल कहीं ना कहीं किसी के
पास कभी ना कभी आए होंगे। उस तरह की
टैक्टिक का यूज करना या बिटकॉइन
सेक्सटॉर्शन सेक्सटोशन मतलब कि आप कोई भी
वीडियो देख रहेगे या किसी
मतलब कि आपको हरास करने के लिए आपको अगर
हम बात करें सभी 18 प्लस होंगे तो आपको
हरास करने के लिए आपके फोन किसी भी फोन पे
आपका फेस लगा दिया जाए तो उसमें भी क्या
है आपके पैसे लेने के लिए इस टाइप से या
फिर कोई फेसिंग ईमेल होगी सोशल मीडिया थे
या कोई फेक लॉगिन पेज ऑल कम्स अंडर क्या
है? सारे के सारे क्या करते हैं? सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़ करते हैं। और सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी का यूज़
किया जाता है। पहले उस पर रिसर्च की जाती
है। फिर आपको फंसाया जाता है। एक्सप्लइट,
एग्जीक्यूट और प्रॉफिट आपसे कमाया जाता
है। तो स्कैमर्स भी क्या करते हैं?
स्कैमर्स भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग को बहुत
अच्छे से परफॉर्म करते हैं। आई होप सबको
समझ में आ गया होगा। पूरे यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है? एग्जांपल्स क्लियर है सबको?
स्टूडेंट्स छोड़ के जा रहे हैं क्लास को
बीच में। मजा नहीं आ रहा शायद स्टूडेंट्स
को।
नेक्स्ट एक और एग्जांपल लेते हैं। एक और
एग्जांपल लेते हैं। यह रहा फॉर एग्जांपल्स
कि आपने किसी के साथ एक फेक रिलेशनशिप
बिल्ड किया। ठीक है? आप किसी के साथ एक
फेक रिलेशनशिप या फिकिटियस रिलेशनशिप
बिल्ड करते हो। जहां पर आप एक फेक
कैरेक्टर प्ले कर रहे हो। जहां पर आप क्या
कर रहे हो? एक फेक कैरेक्टर प्ले कर रहे
हो। जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल हम लेते हैं कि आप
क्या कर रहे हो कि रिक्रूटमेंट एजेंट का
एक फेक कैरेक्टर प्ले कर रहे हो या कोई एक
आईटी स्पोर्ट इंजीनियर या आईटी स्पोर्ट
स्टाफ बन रहे हो। या फिर आपने क्या किया?
आप कैरेक्टर प्ले कर रहे हो कि मैं एक
एचआर ऑफिसर हूं। आप अपने आप को एचआर ऑफिसर
बता रहे हो। मतलब एक एचआर ऑफिसर आप अपने
आप को बता रहे हो कि और उसके बाद क्या कर
रहे हो टारगेट एंप्लॉय के एंप्लई के साथ
क्या कर रहे हो चैट करते हो कम्युनिकेशन
इस्टैब्लिश करते हो तो मेन मोटो क्या है
कि आप जब कोई फेक रिलेशनशिप इस्टैब्लिश
करते हो और फेक रिलेशनशिप इस्टैब्लिश करने
के बाद आप कोई एक फेक नॉन रियल कैरेक्टर
प्ले करते हो तो उस कैरेक्टर को प्ले करने
का आपका मेन मोटो क्या होता है मेन मकसद
होता है आपका बातों ों बातों में टारगेट
एंप्लई से इंसाइडर इंफॉर्मेशन निकलवाना।
ठीक है? जो इनाइडर इंफॉर्मेशन है वो
निकलवाने की कोशिश करना। जैसे यहां पर देख
सकते हैं कि हे आई एम टीचिंग रीचिंग आउट
फ्रॉम सोनसो कंपनी सोनसो आईटी स्पोर्ट। तो
उसने एक क्वेश्चन पूछा। ठीक है? हेल्प
मांगी। बंदे ने क्या बोला? नो प्रॉब्लम।
आई एम रेडी टू हेल्प। तो उसने क्या किया?
एक फेक कैरेक्टर प्ले कर रहा था। किसका
फेक कैरेक्टर था आपका? आपका आईटी स्पोर्ट
इंजीनियर का या फिर आईटी स्पोर्ट स्टाफ का
या एक एचआर ऑफिसर का या फिर एक
रिक्रूटमेंट एजेंट का। तो उसने चैट के
जरिए क्या-क्या किया? उसके डिपार्टमेंट के
बारे में पता लगा लिया कि वो फाइनेंस
ऑपरेटर है। उसके रोल्स और रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
के बारे में पता लगा लिया कि ओके वो वेंडर
पेमेंट या बजट वगैरह या फाइनेंस एनालिसिस
डिपार्टमेंट हैंडल करता है। वो कौन-कौन से
टूल्स यूज़ करते हैं? जैसे Microsoft
Office हो गया, एक्सेल हो गया, वीपीए वी
यूज करते हैं और आईटी स्पोर्ट जो उनका
डिपार्टमेंट है उसके कांटेक्ट लिस्ट या
उसकी ईमेल्स उसने फाइंड आउट कर ली। कौन सा
ईमेल प्लेटफार्म यूज़ करते हैं? उसके बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल ली। उसके बाद वो
उनकी काम करने की पॉलिसी क्या है? रिमोट
वर्क करते हैं या डेली जाते हैं। मतलब
उसने बातों बातों में एक फेक कैरेक्टर से
इतनी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन क्या कर ली? कलेक्ट
कर ली। जब इतनी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन एक अटैकर
के पास आ गई तो क्या होगा? वह अटैकर इसके
बेस पर एक रिसोर्स रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
करेगा। उसकी प्रोफाइल रेडी करेगा और फिर
इसी के बेस पर नेक्स्ट टारगेट या नेक्स्ट
अटैक की प्लानिंग करेगा। आई होप आई एम
क्लियर कि एग्जांपल भी आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा। तो नाउ एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स सच
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन मे हेल्प इन टू मेजर फेजेस।
अगर हम बात करें एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स आपका
मेन गोल दो चीजों पर होता है। आपका मेन
गोल जब भी आप कोई भी पेन टेस्टिंग करते हो
ड्यूरिंग सोशल सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़
करते हो पेन टेस्टिंग में तो आपके दो मेन
गोल होते हैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करने का।
पहला होता है इनिशियली दिस कुड बी
बेनिफिशियल इन द रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट फज़
वेयर द टेस्टर सेट अप द इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
प्रिपेयर प्रिटेक्स्ट क्रिएट सिनेरियोज़
एंड सिमुलेटर टैक्स। मतलब या तो आप ऐसी
जानकारी निकलवाना चाहते हो या आपको ऐसी
जानकारी चाहिए जो आपको रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
फेज में हेल्प करें। पहली जरूरत यह होती
है पेंटेस्टर की या फिर दूसरी जरूरत क्या
हो सकती है? एडिशनली इट कुड बी बेनिफिशियल
इन पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन फेस वेयर द टेस्टर
एम टू रेप्लिकेट हाउ एन अटैकर माइट
पर्स्यूड ए टारगेट टू ओपन ए फाइल क्रिएट ए
लिंक और इंगेज इन ए रिस्की एक्शन या फिर
क्या हो सकता है कि आपको कोई ऐसी डिटेल
चाहते हो या आपको कोई एक ऐसी डिटेल चाहिए
जो आपके पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन फेज में हेल्प
करे या जो आपका पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन फेज है
उसको आसान बना दे जैसे हो सकता है कि
ओपलोड एग्जिट करवाने के लिए आप वह इन
चाहिए कि फाइल को कैसे ओपन कर सकते हैं या
लिंक को कैसे क्लिक करेंगे या फिर थोड़ा
वो एक्शन कैसे परफॉर्म करवाना है रिस्की
यह इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए फिर या तो यह
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन फज़ के
लिए या फिर चाहिए कौन सी रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट फज़ के लिए तो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
में सबसे प्राइमरी दो ही मेजर फेस के लिए
हम यूज़ करते हैं एज ए पेंटेस्टर
ड्यूरिंग पेन टेस्टिंग फॉर जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का मेन गोल होता है। या तो
हमें वो इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए जो हमें रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट फज़ में हेल्प करे या फिर वो
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए जो हमारे पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूशन फेज में हेल्प करे। ठीक है?
या वो चाहिए पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन फज़ में
हेल्प करें। तो नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं
कि
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
टारगेटिंग द वीकेस्ट लिंक। देखो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक का सबसे बड़ा और सबसे
मेन गोल होता है टेक्निकल कंट्रोल्स को
बाईपास करना। अब टेक्निकल कंट्रोल्स आपके
फायर वाल्स हो सकते हैं, आपके एंटीवायरस
हो सकते हैं या फिर आपके एडीआर हो सकते
हैं। और आपका सवाल अब यह हो सकता है सर यह
बाईपास कैसे होते हैं? यह बाईपास कैसे
होंगे? यह बाईपास होंगे सिक्योरिटी चेन की
सबसे कमजोर कड़ी को टारगेट करके। और सबको
पता है सिक्योरिटी चेन की सबसे कमजोर कड़ी
क्या है?
एमंप्लई
सबसे कमजोर कड़ी कौन है? एमंप्लई
सबसे कमजोर को कौन है? एमंप्लई तो दी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस
तो कैसे? ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इन्वेस्ट
सिग्निफिकेंटली इन सिक्योरिटी टूल्स। दे
इंप्लीमेंट ए वैरायटी ऑफ़ टेक्नोलॉजीस
इंक्लूडिंग फायर वाल्स, एंटीवायर
सॉफ्टवेयर, एरिया सॉल्यूशन, सिम सिस्टम्स,
नेटवर्किंग मॉनिटरिंग टूल्स एसेट्रा एंड
एसेट्रा एंड न्यूमरियस अदर डिफेंसिव
मेजर्स कि
जितनी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है सबको पता है कि
उनको अपने कंप्यूटर को बेस्ट तरीके से
कैसे सिक्योर करना है या बेस्ट तरीके से
कैसे सिक्योर किया जाता है। ठीक है? ये
जितनी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है इस चीज के बारे
में सबको पता है। इसलिए वो क्या करती हैं?
वो जितने भी सिक्योरिटी टूल्स हैं उसमें
बहुत ज्यादा अमाउंट में इन्वेस्ट करते
हैं। चाहे और इन्वेस्ट करते हैं किसके
ऊपर? उस टेक्नोलॉजी के ऊपर जो क्या करें?
उनके डिफेंसिव को ज्यादा मजबूत करे। जैसे
फायरवॉल हो गया, एंटीवायरस सॉलशंस हो गए
या एडीआर सॉलशंस हो गए, सिम सिस्टम्स हो
गए या एडवांस नेटवर्क मॉनिटिंग टूल्स हो
गए या एक्सेस कंट्रोल ही क्यों ना लगाने
हो। मतलब उन सारे डिफेंसिव मेजर्स पे वो
क्या करते हैं? बहुत ज्यादा अमाउंट में
इन्वेस्ट करते हैं सिक्योर करने के लिए।
बट हाउएवर देयर इज़ वन एक्स्पेक्ट ऑफ़
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन दैट कैन नॉट बी सेफगार्ड
लाइक ए मशीन द एंप्लई। लेकिन हां
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर एक और एक ऐसा
एस्पेक्ट है जिसको आप मशीनों की तरह
सेफगार्ड नहीं कर सकते जिसका नाम है
एंप्लॉय वहां काम करने वाले लोग उसको आप
मशीनों की तरह सेफगार्ड नहीं कर सकते वुमस
कैन एक्सपीरियंस फटीग कैन बी इली
डिस्ट्रक्टेड फील अंडर प्रेशर्स ट्रस्ट द
रोंग इंडिविजुअल्स एंड मेक मिस्टेक्सेस अब
जो लोग होते हैं क्या है वह थकते भी
डिस्ट्रैक्ट भी होते हैं, प्रे अंडर
प्रेशर भी होते हैं और गलत लोगों पर
विश्वास भी कर लेते हैं और गलतियां भी कर
देते हैं। इन ए कॉर्पोरेट एनवायरमेंट
एंप्लाइज फ्रीक्वेंटली मैनेज मल्टीपल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज कनकरेंटली। अभी किसी भी
कॉर्पोरेट एनवायरमेंट की बात करें कोई भी
एक एंप्लॉय एक साथ बहुत सारी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज को हैंडल कर रहा होता
है। जैसे कि जैसे कोई ईमेल आई उस पे सेम
टाइम रिसोंड करना। मीटिंग्स के अंदर
एक्टिवली पार्टिसिपेट करना या जो डेडलाइन
होगी कंपनी का काम करने की उसको मीट करना
कंपनी जो क्लाइंट उसके साथ बातचीत करना या
फिर जो इंटरनल रिक्वेस्ट होते हैं जो
इंटरनल्स काम होते हैं जो इंटरनल वर्क
होता है उसको एड्रेस करना या फिर जो
स्ट्रेस है कंपनी का वर्क रिलेटेड स्ट्रेस
है उसको मैनेज करना इतनी सारी मल्टीपल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी एक एंप्लई किसी भी कंपनी
के अंदर हैंडल कर रहा होता है एक साथ ठीक
है एक एंप्लई इन सारी चीजों को एक साथ
हैंडल कर रहा होता है। इसलिए जब बात आती
है आपके एंप्लई लेवल पर तो
वहां पर लोग क्या होते हैं? थके हुए होते
हैं। वहां पर बिजी होते हैं। ठीक है? और
इसीलिए हाई चांसेस होते हैं कि वह अपनी
सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग को या तो भूल जाए या
फिर सही से फॉलो ना कर पाए या हो सकता है
कि सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग में वह इतना अच्छे
से ध्यान नहीं दे पाए या उनको कोई डाउट
आया वह सही से पूछ नहीं पाए। दीज़ आर द
रीज़ंस। या तो वह थके हुए थे, डिस्ट्रैक्ट
हो गए या अंडर प्रेशर थे या गलत लोगों के
साथ दोस्ती हो गई थी या फिर वो मल्टीपल
रिसोंसिटी के नीचे दबे हुए थे। ठीक है?
दीज़ आर द रीज़ंस। नाउ इन दीज़ सरकमस्ट्ससेस
इवन ए ट्रेंड एंप्लई माइट ओवरलुक
सिक्योरिटी प्रोटोकॉल्स नेगलेक्ट टू
थ्रोली वेरीफाई रिक्वेस्ट। अब इतने सारे
सरकमस्ट्ससेस होने के बावजूद चाहे एंप्लई
चाहे मैं ही क्यों ना हो चाहे आप ही क्यों
ना हो कितने भी ट्रेंड हो एंप्लॉय हो इतने
सारे सरकमस्ट्ससेस इतने सारी प्रॉब्लम्स
होने के बावजूद आप जानबूझकर भी सिक्योरिटी
प्रोटोकॉल्स को ओवरलुक कर दोगे या
नेगलेक्ट कर दोगे या उस रिक्वेस्ट को
वेरीफाई करना ही नेगलेक्ट कर दोगे बिकॉज़
इतनी सारी चीजें चल रही होती हैं। भले
आपको कितनी ट्रेनिंग की गई हो, कितनी भी
ट्रेनिंग आपको दी गई हो, कितने आपके
ट्रेनिंग वर्कशॉप लिए गए हो कंपनी में। बट
जितने भी सरकमस्ट्ससेस की मैंने बात की,
थका हुआ होना, मल्टीपल प्रेशर्स होना, यह
सारी चीजें होने के बावजूद क्या है कि आप
फिर भी अपनी सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग्स को भूल
जाते हो, नेगलेक्ट कर देते हो। उसका और
यही जो नेग्लिजेंस है, इसी का अटैकर्स
क्या करते हैं? एडवांटेज लेते हैं, उठाते
हैं, उसी का फायदा उठाते हैं। तो इन योर
रोल्स एज ए पेंटेस्ट इट्स योर
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी टू पिन पॉइंट सिनेरियोस
वेयर ह्यूमन एरर्स कुड रिजल्ट इन
सिक्योरिटी वनेबिलिटीज। बाय आइडेंटिफाइंग
दीज़ वीकनेसेस दी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस कैन
एनहांस इट्स ट्रेनिंग प्रोग्राम्स,
पॉलिसीज, वेरिफिकेशन प्रोसेस एंड टेक्निकल
सेफ कार्ड्स। मतलब क्या है कि बॉटम लाइन
यह है कि एक पेंटस के रूप में आपका काम है
आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है उन सभी गैप्स या
इश्यूज को फाइंड आउट करना जहां से एक
इंसान गलती कर सकता है और ताकि और दूसरी
बात दूसरा मेजर रोल क्या है आपका एज ए
पेंटस्टर उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस को वो सारे लूप
होल्स बताना जहां से एक रियल हैकर्स उनके
ऊपर अटैक कर सकता है और साथ के साथ
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को यह भी बताना कि यह लूप
होल था। इसके लिए आप ये ट्रेनिंग
प्रोग्राम अप्लाई कर सकते हो या पॉलिसी
अप्लाई कर सकते हो या यह वेरिफिकेशन ऐड कर
सकते हो या एक सेफगार्ड ऐड कर सकते हो।
एंड द गोल इज नॉट टू असाइन ब्लेम टू
एंप्लाइजज़। लेकिन हमेशा ध्यान रखना अपनी
लाइफ में कि एज ए पेंटेस्टर्स आपका गोल
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में किसी एंप्लॉय एक
सिंगल एंप्लई के ऊपर ब्लेम डालना नहीं
होता। इसके बारे में हम डिस्कस करेंगे
काफी डिटेल्स में कि ओके हमें क्या करना
है क्या-क्या चीजों का बात किन-किन बातों
का ध्यान रखना है इस चीज के बारे में
डिस्कस करेंगे लेकिन मैं आपको एक हिंट दे
रहा हूं कि आपका काम है आपका काम यह नहीं
है कि किसी एक सिम सिंगल एंप्लॉय को ब्लेम
करना या जिसकी वजह से उस एंप्लई को
प्रॉब्लम आ सकती है। आपका काम है एनहांस
ओवरऑल सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम्स मतलब उस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की जो सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम्स
को एनहांस करना उसके लिए आपको पॉलिसी
रिकमेंड करना या आपको कौन सी पॉलिसी
रिकमेंड करनी है या क्या वेरिफिकेशन होनी
चाहिए यह सारी नॉलेज आपके पास होनी चाहिए
या क्या आपको इंप्लीमेंट करना है ये चीजें
आपको अपनी रिपोर्ट में ऐड करनी पड़ेंगी
दैट इज आवर रिस्पांसिबिलिटी इसलिए मैंने
आपको बताया आपका मेन काम क्या है उन सारे
गैप्स और इशज़ को फाइंड आउट करना जहां से
एक इंसान गलती कर सकता है ड्यूरिंग
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है?
यहां तक सबको समझ में आया कि व्हाट आई एम
ट्राइंग टू से और व्हाट आई एम ट्राइंग टू
टीचिंग यू।
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? प्लीज जितने भी
स्टूडेंट्स हैं आप पांच हो, छ हो, सात हो,
आठ हो या दो हो। सभी मेरी रिक्वेस्ट है सब
लोग यस या नो
आंसर
दो ताकि मुझे यह पता चले कि आप लोग सो
नहीं रहे हो। आप लोग बोर नहीं हो रहे हो।
ओके? क्योंकि अगर मुझे यह पता चलेगा कि आप
लोग इंटरेस्टेड हो। आप लोगों को इंटरेस्ट
आ रहा है। बोर नहीं हो रहे हो तो अगर आप
बोर भी हो रहेगे तो मुझे बताओगे तो मैं
क्या करूंगा ना आपको कंटीन्यूसली डिलीवर
करता नहीं चलूंगा मैं आपको फिर समझाता
चलूंगा थोड़ा और डिटेल्स में जाऊंगा या
चीजें अपने टेक्निक को बदलने की कोशिश
करूंगा गेटिंग माय पॉइंट कि मैं आपको क्या
कहने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं तो नेक्स्ट अब
बात करते हैं हम एक्सप्लइटिंग बेसिक
ह्यूमन इंस्टिंग मतलब इसका मतलब क्या है
कि देखो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का मेन काम क्या है कोई
बताना चाहेगा कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का मेन
काम क्या है
व्हाट इज द मेन वर्क ऑफ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग?
मेन काम क्या है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का?
एनीवन
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का मेन काम क्या है?
बताओ।
स्लाइड पे भी लिखा हुआ है। स्लाइड को भी
देख के आप बता सकते हो कि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का मेन काम क्या है? व्हाट इज
द
मेन गोल या मेन वर्क? मेन काम क्या है?
देखो, मैं बता देता हूं आपको। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का मेन काम यह है कि एंप्लॉय
को एक ऐसी सिचुएशन में डाल दिया जाए।
एंप्लॉय को या किसी भी टारगेट
इंसान को टारगेटेड इंसान को किसी भी या
किसी भी एंप्लॉय को या किसी टारगेट
व्यक्ति को एक ऐसी सिचुएशन में डाल दिया
जाए जहां वह अपने दिमाग की जगह अपनी बेसिक
इंस्टिंक्ट या नॉर्मल सोशल बिहेवियर पर
डिपेंड करने लगे। आई एम रिपीटिंग अगेन कि
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का मेन काम है कि किसी
भी टारगेट एंप्लॉय को ऐसी सिचुएशन में डाल
दिया जाए जहां वो अपने दिमाग की जगह अपने
बेसिक इंस्टिंक्ट या नॉर्मल सोशल बिहेवियर
पर डिपेंड करने लगे। मतलब जब उसके पास वह
सिचुएशन आए उस सिचुएशन पर वह ज्यादा सोचे
ना। किसी भी इंसान के पास जब कोई भी
सिचुएशन आती है तो
नॉर्मली क्या करता है? वह सिचुएशन को टैकल
करने के लिए सोचता है, समझता है उस
सिचुएशन को रिएक्ट करने की कोशिश करता है।
करूं या ना करूं? यह चीज आपको अपने टारगेट
को कभी भी नहीं देनी है। ठीक है? मतलब
उसको क्या करना है? उसको ऐसी सिचुएशन में
रखना है जहां पर उसका जो दिमाग है वो ओनली
नॉर्मल सोशल बिहेवियर पर डिपेंड करे। अब
नॉर्मल सोशल बिहेवियर की बात करें तो एक
अटैकर इंसान के दिमाग जो इंसान के पांच
सबसे कॉमन ट्रेट का फायदा उठाता है कि कोई
भी एक अटैकर होता है ना यह जो आपको
स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे रही है ये पांच वो
कॉमन ट्रेट्स होती हैं या वो पांच वो कॉमन
ह्यूमन इंस्टिंक्ट्स होते हैं जो
किसी भी अटैकर के लिए बहुत ज्यादा
बेनिफिशियल होते हैं और ये वो पांच ही
इंस्टिंक्ट होती है जो ज्यादातर यूज़ होती
हैं जो इंसान इंसान इंसान को मजबूर करती
है एक्शन लेने के लिए एक्शन परफॉर्म करने
के लिए। मतलब मेरे कहने का मतलब है कि जब
मैंने आपको बताया था कि एंप्लई को ऐसी
सिचुएशन में डाल देना कि उसका जो अपने
नॉर्मल सोशल बिहेवियर पर डिपेंड करे। यह
नॉर्मल सोशल बिहेवियर है। कौन सा है? जैसे
हेल्पिंग इन नेचर
आपका दूसरा ट्रस्ट, अप्रूवल सीकिंग,
फियर ऑफ अथॉरिटी या क्फ्लिक्ट अविडेंस।
मतलब अब जब इन पांच सिचुएशन में आ गया है
आपका एंप्लई तो मतलब वह एक्स्ट्रा दिमाग
लगाएगा नहीं। मतलब कि एंप्लॉय को ज्यादा
दिमाग लगाने नहीं देना है। उसको
उस इन पांच सिचुएशन में से किसी भी एक
सिचुएशन में डाल देना है और आपका काम हो
जाएगा। ठीक है? इन पांच सिचुएशन में से
किसी भी एक सिचुएशन में उसको क्या कर देना
है?
इनफ्लुएंस करना है, मैनपुलेट करना है या
इन सिचुएशन ऐसी पांच इन यह पांच सिचुएशन
में से कोई भी एक सिचुएशन क्रिएट करनी है
जो एंप्लई के सामने हो जिससे क्या हो? वो
अपने नॉर्मल सोशल बिहेवियर का यूज़ करें ना
कि अपने दिमाग का यूज़ करें। ठीक है? तो
सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं सबसे पहले जो
आपका इंस्टिंक्ट है वो आपका डिजायर टू बी
हेल्पफुल। डिजायर टू बी हेल्पफुल। मतलब
लोग नेचुरली दूसरों की मदद करना पसंद करते
हैं।
सब लोग एग्री हो?
लोग अक्सर
दूसरों की मदद करना पसंद करते हैं। तो
इसलिए पहला इंस्ट्रिंक्ट क्या है हमारा?
दी डिजायर टू बी हेल्पफुल। यह रहा डिजायर
टू बी हेल्पफुल। नीचे दिखाई दे रहा होगा
डिजायर टू बी हेल्पफुल। मतलब यह क्या है?
कि लोग अक्सर दूसरों की मदद करना पसंद
करते हैं। जैसे यहां पर देखो कि हे आई एम
न्यू आईटी टेक्नशियन। आई एम सीटिंग सेटिंग
अप अकाउंट्स एंड फ्यू डिटेल्स ऑन सो। अब
ये सारी चीजें क्या है कि प्रोफाइल बिल्ड
किसने की? अटैकर ने सब कुछ प्रोफाइल
क्योंकि ये ये सारी प्रोफाइल किसकी बिल्ड
की हुई होगी। यह मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
किसी भी कंपनी के अंदर बता रहा हूं। आप ये
सारी चीज आप ऑनलाइन भी कर सकते हो। तो
आपको क्या करना है?
बंदे के
हेल्पफुल नेचर का फायदा उठाना है। ठीक है?
तो उस हेल्पफुल नेचर में बंदा कुछ भी कर
देगा। अपनी नेटवर्क इनेशन दे देगा। अकाउंट
एक्सेस इनेशन, आईटी कांटेक्ट की डिटेल,
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी ये सब हेल्पफुल नेचर।
ठीक है? दिस इज योर हेल्पफुल नेचर। जिससे
क्या होगा? एक तो क्या ट्रस्ट बनेगा।
दूसरा आप सिंपल क्वेश्चन पूछ रहे हो। उसको
शक भी नहीं होगा। ठीक है? यह चीज है।
दूसरी टेक्निक क्या है?
टेंडेंसी टू ट्रस्ट पीपल।
दूसरी जो ह्यूमन इंस्टिंक्ट है टेंडेंसी
टू ट्रस्ट पीपल। अब इंसानों को बाय
डिफॉल्ट जो इंसानों का जो बाय डिफॉल्ट
नेचर होता है वह होता है सामने वाले पर
भरोसा करना।
किसी भी इंसान का या कोई भी व्यक्ति है
उसका बाय डिफॉल्ट नेचर क्या होता है? कि
वह सामने वाले पर ट्रस्ट करता है। सामने
वाले पर वह विश्वास करता है। एवरीवन
एग्री करते हो
और इसी चीज का फायदा उठाना ठीक है इसी चीज
का फायदा उठाना जैसे कि एक नया कलीग आया
एंप्लॉय उसने क्या किया कि ओथे आई एम
गेटिंग फमिलियर विद थिंग्स उसने उसके साथ
अप्रोच किया वो ओके ओके श्योर श्योर पूरा
ट्रस्ट जीता उसके बाद काम कर दिया
ठीक है थर्ड चीज क्या होती है आपकी डिजायर
फॉर अप्रूवल डिजायर फॉर अप्रूवल
ठीक ठीक है? हर कोई चाहता है उसको
एप्रिसिएशन या अप्रूवल मिले या अवार्ड
मिले। मतलब उसको काम करने पर एप्रिसिएशन
मिले। मतलब उसकी तारीफ हो। अब दुनिया में
यह बताओ तारीफ किसको पसंद नहीं है?
तारीफ सबको पसंद है। तो वही चीज है। जैसे
कि एक एग्जांपल है। यह अटैकर के द्वारा
फेक प्रोफाइल की हुई है। देखें रॉबर्ट
एंडरसन
देखो। हाय एलेक्स आई जस्ट वांट टू से
एक्सीलेंट वर्क ऑन दैट रिसेंट प्रोजेक्ट।
द लीडरशिप टीम वाज रियली इंप्रेस्ड। योर
अटेंशन टू डिटेल्स एंड ओनरशिप रियली सूट
आउट। यू आर वन ऑफ आवर टॉप परफॉर्मर्स।
भाई क्या किया इसका? ईगो बूस्ट कर दिया।
इसका जो गार्ड था, डिफेंस था, वह लोअर
डाउन हो गया। अभी क्या किया? उसके बाद
थैंक यू सो मच। एलेक्स ने भेजा मैसेज।
ओके, आई रियली अप्रिशिएट दी काइंड ऑफ़
वर्ड्स हैप्पी टू हेल्प व्हेनवर आई कैन
मतलब हेल्पिंग नेचर एक्टिवेट।
ओके। तो रॉबर्ट ने भी बोला भाई दैट्स
व्हाट आई लाइक टू हियर। ओके अच्छी बात है।
तो मुझे कुछ आपसे इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए थी।
कुछ एक अर्जेंट थी। थोड़ा सा काम था मुझे।
मैं आपको एक बाद में क्या करता हूं? फ्री
होके मैसेज करता हूं। सेम टाइम नहीं
मांगा। फ्री होके मैसेज करता हूं। मतलब
ट्रस्ट भी जीतता है। सारी चीजें मतलब एक
नेचुरल जो चीजें होती है ना नेचुरल
प्रोसेस होती है। उस नेचुरल प्रोसेस का
फायदा उठाया। अब इस सिचुएशन में आप ही
देखिए कि तारीफ मिल गई बंदे को।
ठीक है? तारीफ मिल गई, एप्रिसिएशन मिल
गया, अप्रूवल मिल गया बंदे को। भले ही
उसका बॉस उसको गाली देता हो या उसको उसका
बॉस उसकी इज्जत ना करता हो या बाकी स्टाफ
उसको कुछ भी नहीं मानता हो। इसने इसका
अप्रिसिएशन दे दिया। बोला हां हां हां हां
यार बॉस तो तारीफ कर रहा था लेकिन मेरे
सामने कभी करता नहीं। तो हो गया काम। अब
इसके जो डिफेंस करने वाले जो गार्ड थे कि
अरे इसको यह लगेगा कि स्पैमिंग आ रही है
कुछ आ रही है। वह तो डाउन कर दिए ना। यह
काम करेगा। एवरीवन क्लियर नेक्स्ट आता है
आपका
फियर ऑफ गेटिंग इन ट्रबल। इसमें मैंने
लिखा नहीं फियर ऑफ गेटिंग इन ट्रबल मतलब
कोई भी इंसान बॉस या किसी अथॉरिटी से डांट
खाने से खाना नहीं चाहता। मतलब हर कोई
अपने बॉस या अथॉरिटी से डरता है। हर एक
इंसान। ठीक है? अब जैसे कि अब यह देखो एक
ईमेल आई।
इमीडिएट एक्शन रिक्वायर्ड
आई नीड टु प्रोसेस ए वायर ट्रांसफर सो एंड
सो यह दे मस्ट बी कंप्लेंट सो विद इन 30
मिनट मतलब क्या हुआ टाइम सेंसिटिविटी हाई
प्रायोरिटी पोटेंशियल रिस्क कहां से आया
सीईओ
कहां से आया भैया सीईओ अब एक बात बताओ आप
एंप्लॉय हो किसी भी कंपनी के अंदर सीईओ की
मेल देख के उसके साथ आर्गुमेंट करोगे
क्योंकि एक तो अथॉरिटी है। दूसरी उसमें
अर्जेंसी है। उसके बाद अगर उसने आपने बॉस
के साथ
कुछ बहस कर दी तो भाई उसके क्सिक्वेंसेस
भी झेलने पड़ेंगे।
तो इसलिए फियर ऑफ गेटिंग इन ट्रबल भी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में बहुत ज्यादा यूज़ किया।
जैसे कि कोई भी इंसान अपने बॉस से या
अथॉरिटी से डांट खाना खाना नहीं चाहता।
हमेशा उसको अपने बॉस या अथॉरिटी से डांट
का डर लगता है। डांट से डरता है। दैट इज
व्हाई इसका भी आप पूरा फायदा उठा सकते हो।
उठा सकते हो। नेक्स्ट अगर हम बात करें
फिफ्थ कौन सा है? अवॉयडिंग कन्फ्लिक्ट और
आर्गुममेंट्स। अवॉयडिंग कॉन्फ्लिक्ट और
आर्गुममेंट्स। लोग आमतौर पर क्या करते
हैं?
बहसबाजी या झगड़ों से बचने की कोशिश करते
हैं। बहसबाजी या झगड़ों को अवॉइड करते
हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल यह अब इसका बॉस होगा या
कोई भी होगा व्हाटएवर वेंडर होगा। उसने
क्या बोला? देखो, आई नीड दिस इन राइट नाउ।
डोंट मेक दिस मोर डिफिकल्ट देन इट नीड टू
बी। यू
डू वांट टू हेल्प राइट। ठीक है? मतलब अभी
साइकोलॉजिकल गेम है। हर कोई इंसान
क्फ्लिक्ट अवॉयड करता है। क्या आप इस चीज
के लिए
थोड़ा सा भी सोचोगे इंफॉर्मेशन देने से
पहले? नहीं सोचोगे। बिकॉज़ आप बहसबाजी नहीं
करना चाहते। किसी के साथ आप किसी के साथ
झगड़ा नहीं करना चाहते। इसी वजह से क्या
हो गया? आप वो इंफॉर्मेशन भी दे दोगे।
वो इंफॉर्मेशन भी क्या कर दोगे आप? दे
दोगे। अंडरस्टुड? पांच चीजें मैं आपको
बताई। पहली चीज मैं कि लोग नेचुरली दूसरों
की मदद करना पसंद करते हैं। इसलिए सोशल
इंजीनियर्स का भी फायदा उठाते हैं। दूसरा
क्या था? टेंडेंसी टू ट्रस्ट पीपल।
इंसानों को बाय डिफॉल्ट। इंसानों का जो
बाय डिफॉल्ट नेचर होता है, वह सामने वाले
पर ट्रस्ट करने का नेचर होता है। डिजायर
फॉर अप्रूवल। हर कोई चाहता है कि उनको
एप्रिसिएशन या अप्रूवल मिले। अब फोर्थ वन
कौन सा था? कोई भी अपने बॉस या अथॉरिटी से
डांट नहीं खाना चाहता। सबको डांट का डर
लगा रहता है। पांचवा कौन सा था जो आपके
सामने है कि कोई भी इंसान आमतौर पर
बहसबाजी या झगड़ों से बचना चाहता है। अब
यह पांच ऐसी चीजें हैं इन पांचों चीजों का
फायदा उठाता है कौन? अटैकर। फिर से समराइज
करूं या पता चल गया?
फिर से समराइज करूं। आपको पता चल गया
कौन सी वह पांच चीजें हैं।
हेल्पिंग इन नेचर
लोगों पर विश्वास करना
एप्रिसिएशन या अप्रूवल के लिए काम करना
बॉस या अथॉरिटी का डर होना बहसबाजी और
झगड़ों से बचने के लिए यह पांच वो चीजें
हैं जो सोशल इंजीनियर फायदा उठाता है किसी
भी एंप्लॉय का। अगर किसी भी ऑफिस में मैं
भी होऊंगा, तो मैं भी इन पांच चीजों को
हमेशा अवॉइड करूंगा। और इन पांच चीजों पर
हर एक ह्यूमन नेचर काम करता है। कोई भी
इंसान हो धरती पर या हर एक चीज हर हर एक
इंसान के ऊपर यह पांच चीजें इफ़ेक्ट करती
ही करती हैं।
क्लियर? यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
अंडरस्टुड?
बताइए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का ऐसा टॉपिक कहां
पर मिलेगा? कहीं पर है ऐसा टॉपिक सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के ऊपर कहीं पर भी मिलेगा तो
बताओ
कहीं पर भी
बताओ चैट में बताओ।
चैट में बताओ
यह समन आई एम प्लानिंग दिस वन।
चलिए फिर
नेक्स्ट
ये इसका
ध्यान से देखिए। जो चीज मैं आपको बताई जो
पांच चीजें मैंने आपको बताई आपके पास दो
रास्ते हैं। दूसरा
क्विक इजी रिस्की एक यह रास्ता आप फॉलो कर
सकते हो या फिर थोड़ा सा सोचो वेरीफाई करो
आगे बढ़ो। आप सेफ रहोगे या फिर
ट्रस्ट करोगे ब्लाइंडली या ड्रे ड्रे
रहोगे या हेल्पफुल नेचर रखोगे या फिर वो
जो मैं पांच चीजों के बारे में वो किया और
उसके बेस पर डिसीजन लोगे तो फिर आपके लिए
यह रास्ता है यह वाला रास्ता जिसमें आप
कभी भी फंस सकते हो।
अंडरस्टुड?
तो डिपेंड्स ऑन द ऑन यू गाइस कि आपके पास
दो रास्ते हैं। सोचो वेरीफाई करो फिर काम
करो या फिर आप अपने ब्लाइंडली ट्रस्ट करो
और डरते रहो। इमोशंस पे कंट्रोल मत करो।
हेल्पफुल नेचर का फायदा उठवाते रहो। हमेशा
अथॉरिटी से डरते रहो और क्फ्लिक्ट अवॉइड
करते रहो। लोग आपका फायदा उठाते रहेंगे या
सोशल इंजीनियर्स आपका फायदा उठाते रहेंगे।
ओके नाउ अभी बात करते हैं व्हाई इज सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग सो पावरफुल व्हाई इज सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग सो पावरफुल अब सवाल आता है कि
यह टेक्निक इतनी डेंजरस और इफेक्टिव क्यों
है? यह टेक्निक इतनी डेंजरस और इफेक्टिव
क्यों है?
क्योंकि
जब भी एक अटैकर
किसी भी सिस्टम सिस्टम एक्सेस के लिए
किसी भी एंप्लॉय पर अटैक करता है या किसी
ह्यूमन बीइंग पर अटैक करता है तो ज्यादातर
टाइम क्या करता है? और ज्यादातर टाइम
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बड़े-बड़े सिक्योरिटी
पैराटर्स फायर वाल्स आईडीएस इंट्रोजन
डिटेक्शन सिस्टम्स या आईपीएस इंट्रोजन
प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम से से लड़ना नहीं उसको
इन सब से लड़ना नहीं पड़ता। इन सबको हमें
क्या करता है? वो साइड से निकल जाता है।
हमेशा बाईपास कर देता है। मतलब जब भी कोई
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म करने की सोचता
है तो हमेशा वह चाहता है कि जो भी आउटर
पैरामीटर डिफेंसेस लगे हुए हैं किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के अंदर वो उनके साथ ना
भिड़े। उनके साथ डायरेक्ट उनकी मुलाकात ना
हो। ज्यादा हेडेक ना लेनी पड़े और वो
चुपचाप साइड से निकल जाए। दैट इज व्हाई वह
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज करता है। मतलब इन
ए कन्वेंशनल टेक्निकल अटैक एन अटैकर
टिपिकली हैज़ टू परफॉर्म सेवरल टास्क
स्कैनिंग नेटवर्क आइडेंटिफाइंग ओपन पोर्स
डिस्कवरिंग वनेबिलिटीज एक्सप्लइटिंग
सर्विज बायपासिंग फायर वाल्स इवेडिंग
डिटेक्शंस एस्केलेटिंग प्रिलेजेस एंड दिस
प्रोसेस कैन टेक हावर्स डेज और इवन वीक्स
मतलब यह है कि जब भी आप कोई भी आपके जो
ट्रेडिशनल सर्वर साइड अटैक्स होते हैं या
जब भी आप कोई भी कन्वेंशनल आप अटैक
परफॉर्म करते हो उसमें क्या करते हो आप
पहले नेटवर्क को स्कैन करते हो ओपन पोर्स
को आइडेंटिफाई करते हो वनेबिलिटीज को
डिस्कवर करते हो मिली तो ठीक है नहीं मिली
तो तब भी प्रॉब्लम है सर्विज को एक्सप्लइट
करने की कोशिश करते हो फायर वाल्स को
बायपास करते हो डिटेक्शन इवेट करने की
कोशिश करते हो फिर प्रिलज एस्केलेशन करते
हो और ये सारी प्रोसेस में क्या लगता है
ये सारे प्रोसेस में आपके या ये सारी
प्रोसेस परफॉर्म करने में आपको घंटों लग
जाते हैं दिन भी लग जाते हैं और कई बार
आपको कई कई वीक लग जाते हैं सारे काम करने
के लिए हाउएवर विद सोशल इंजीनियरिंग एन
अटैकर मे फोकस ऑन ए पर्सन हु ऑलरेडी
पोजेसेस लेजिटमेट एक्सेस। अभी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में क्या होता है? अटैकर उस
एंप्लॉय या उस व्यक्ति पर फोकस करता है
जिसके पास ऑलरेडी उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर
एक लेजिटमेट एक्सेस है। सिंपल लेदर देन
हैकिंग इनू द सिस्टम द अटैकर पर्स्यूड
समवन विद इन द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन टू ग्रांट देम
एक्सेस। क्या करता है कि वह डायरेक्टली
सिस्टम्स को हैक करने के बजाय उस एक ऐसे
व्यक्ति को फाइंड आउट करता है जिसके पास
वो एक्सेस है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर जिसको
वो कन्वेंस कर सके जिसको वो इन्फ्लुएंस कर
सके जिसको मैनपुलेट करें कर सके और अपना
एक्सेस ग्रांट करवा लेता है दिस एस्पेक्ट
इज़ व्हाट मेक्स सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
पर्टिकुलर
प्रीलियस
ओके नाउ द अटैकर माइट नॉट नीड टू
कंप्रोमाइज द फायर वाल अब यह करने के लिए
अटैकर तो कोई फायर वाल कंप्रोमाइज करनी ना
कोई कॉम्प्लेक्स अटैक एक्सप्लइट बनाना
सर्वर के लिए ना किसी इंटूडेंट डिटेक्शन
को बायपास करना जस्ट उसको क्या करना है इट
ऑल इट टेक वन पर्सन मेकिंग ए सिंगल
मिस्टेक मतलब उसको क्या करना है एक ऐसे
व्यक्ति को फाइंड आउट करना है और उस
व्यक्ति से क्या करनी है गलती करवानी है
मतलब अपना काम निकलवाने के लिए उसे गलती
करवानी है मतलब मेरा यह है सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में कंपनी क्या करती है सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में जो अटैकर्स क्या होते
हैं? कंपनी के किसी एक ऐसे एंप्लॉय को
ढूंढते हैं। उसके साथ इंगेज करते हैं।
इंगेज करके अपना काम निकलवाते हैं। और यह
सारा काम जस्ट इन ए मेट्रो मिनट में हो
जाता है। कई बार सेकंडों में काम हो जाता
है। है और उससे क्या करते हैं? सेंसिटिव
इनेशन कलेक्ट करते हैं या फिर नेटवर्क के
अंदर कोई मालवेयर इंस्टॉल करवाते हैं या
उसको पता भी नहीं चलता। यह सारी चीजों से
चुपचाप करवा लेते हैं। जस्ट मिनटों में
जहां पर घंटे लग रहे थे, दिन लग रहे थे,
जहां पर वीक लग रहे थे। उसको ये मिनटों
में करवा लेते हैं विद द हेल्प ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। इसी वजह से क्या है?
इसी वजह से क्या है? जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
है किसी भी कंपनी के लिए सबसे बड़ा नाइट
मेयर है। आप चाहे कितने भी करोड़ के
सॉफ्टवेयर खरीद लो।
ठीक है? कितने भी फायर वाल्स लगा लो।
कितने भी आईडीएस, आईपीएस या कितना भी
हार्डनिंग कर लो सिस्टम के अंदर।
लेकिन अगर आपका एंप्लई एक छोटी सी भी गलती
कर देता है तो आपके पूरे के पूरे नेटवर्क
को क्या करवा देता है? वो कॉम्प्रोमाइज
करवा देता है। उसकी बैंड बजवा देता है।
ठीक है? कॉम्प्रोमाइज और उसकी बैंड बजवा
देता हूं। चलिए एक कुछ मैं एग्जांपल
समझाता हूं। प्रैक्टिकल सिग्निफिकेंस ऑफ़
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। इन वेरियस नोटेबल
ब्रीचेस अटैकर्स डिड नॉट इनिशिएट देयर
एफर्ट्स विद कॉम्प्लेक्स टेक्निकल
एक्सप्लइट्स। रेदर दे रिलाई ऑन टैिक सच एज
फेसिंग इंपशनेशन
फ्रॉड कम्युनिकेशन क्रेडेंशियल थे
मैनपुलेशन ऑफ एंप्लाइज
मतलब क्या है कि आजकल जितने भी बड़े आपने
डाटा ब्रिजेस सुने होंगे जितने भी बड़े
डेटा ब्रिजेचेस होते हैं या आप साइबर
अटैक्स न्यूज़ में देखते हैं या सुनते हैं
उनमें मैक्सिमम का डायरेक्ट जो संबंध
रहेगा जो मैक्सिमम का जो डायरेक्ट कोज है
वो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
और मैक्सिमम का डायरेक्ट कोज क्या है?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग।
जैसे कि रॉकस्टार गेम का हैक के बारे में
जाना। अगर आपने रॉकस्टार जो गेम था जो हैक
हुआ था उसके बारे में सुना हो। वो भी एक
परफेक्ट एग्जांपल है। जहां टेकर ने क्या
किया था? टेक्निकल हैक करने की बजाय सबसे
पहले क्या किया? उसके एंप्लाइजज़ को
मैनपुलेट किया और उसके इंटरनल रिसोर्सेज
को एक्सेस किया। द रॉकस्टार गेम इंसिडेंट
इज फ्रीक्वेंटली साइटेड एज ए केस वेयर
अटैकर्स एंप्लॉयड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
टैक्टिक टू गेन एक्सेस टू इंटरनल
रिसोर्सेज। ये एक परफेक्ट एग्जांपल है।
Google करके देखना जो रॉकस्टार गेम का जो
हैक हुआ था उसमें में सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
मेन उसका कारण है। तो इससे एक चीज आपको
समझ में आ गई। इवन मेजर कंपनीज़ विद रबस्ट
टेक्निकल डिफेंसेस कैन बी वनेरेबल और
व्हेन ह्यूमन ट्रस्ट इज एक्सप्लइटेड। इसका
मतलब यह है कि आप कितनी भी मजबूत कंपनी
हो, कितने भी उसके मजबूत डिफेंसेस हो, अगर
उसके अंदर काम करने वाले एंप्लॉय अगर वह
वनेबल हैं, उनकी ट्रेनिंग सही से नहीं हो
रही, उनको ज्ञान नहीं है, उनको नॉलेज नहीं
है
या उनमें बहुत ज्यादा वनेबिलिटीज हैं या
उनको कोई भी अटैकर, पेंटेस्टर्स उनको
एक्सप्लइट कर पाता है तो आपके जितने भी
स्ट्रांग डिफेंसेस हैं। सारे के सारे धरे
के धराए रह जाते हैं। सारे के सारे क्या
हो जाते हैं? धरे के धरे रह जाते हैं। ओके
तो यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया गाइस बहुत
कुछ है जो हमें अभी पढ़ना है तो बट नहीं
कवर आ पा आएंगे क्योंकि आप लोग बोर हो
जाओगे। तो बाकी कल करें फिर
कल करें बाकी।
कल करें क्योंकि आज ज्यादा हो जाएगा फिर
थ्योरी क्योंकि थ्योरी को हम एक काम
करेंगे ना हमेशा डिलीवरी रखेंगे 40 टू
मतलब 50 मिनट मैक्स 60 मिनट 1 घंटा इससे
ज्यादा हम थ्योरी पार्ट कवर नहीं करेंगे
बिकॉज़ आप लोग बोर हो जाओगे
ओके अमन पटेल पूछ रहे हैं सर आफ्टर द
प्रैक्टिकल सोशल इंजीनियरिंग वेबिनार विल
बी एबल टू परफॉर्म रियल वर्ल्ड पेन
टेस्टिंग या इनिशियल एक्सेस अटैक्स ऑन ए
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन और रियल इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
देखिए अमन पटेल मैं क्या कर रहा हूं अभी
मैं प्लान कर रहा हूं कि आप लोगों को मैं
कैसे यह डेमोंस्ट्रेशन दिखा सकता हूं मैं
अभी आपको 100% श्योरिटी नहीं दे रहा बट
मैं अभी प्लान कर रहा हूं बिकॉज़ उसके लिए
बहुत सारे आपका अगर डेमोंस्ट्रेशन मुझे
परफॉर्म करना है तो मुझे जगह ढूंढनी
पड़ेगी रिसोर्सेज ढूंढने पड़ेंगे कैसे वो
करवाना है ताकि आप रियल लाइफ के साथ उसको
कोरिलेट करवाएं इतने सारी चीजें वर्कआउट
करने के बाद उसमें लगेगा समय बट मैं आप
लोगों के लिए जेनुइनली सच में उसको मैं
प्लान कर सोच रहा हूं उसके बारे में प्लान
कर रहा हूं जैसे हो जाएगा प्लान हम
रजिस्ट्रेशन ले लेंगे
हां इतनी श्योरिटी अगर मैंने वो आपको
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन दिखाया तो एक चीज बताऊं कि
उसमें जब सारी चीजें रियल टाइप की उसमें
यूज होने वाली हैं तो आप तो डेफिनेटली
उसको कर पाओगे किसी भी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के
ऊपर बट मैं आपको एक चीज बताऊंगा अमन अभी
आप लोग जो रेगुलर आ रहे हो ना मेरी अभी जो
क्लास स्टार्ट हुई है या जितनी भी क्लास
हुई है डोंट मिस ए सिंगल क्लास बिकॉज़ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में बहुत सारी चीजें होती हैं
लीगल अथॉरिटी इललीगल अथॉरिटीज या एज एज
एथिकल हैकर्स मुझे किन चीजों बातों को
ध्यान में रखना चाहिए। कौन-कौन साइकोलॉजी
यूज़ होती हैं? ये सारी चीजें मैं डिस्कस
करने वाला हूं। अटैक कैसे प्रिपेयर करना
है? आई विल आल्सो डिस्कवर। यह सारी चीजें
मैं आपको डिस्कस करने वाला हूं आपके सामने
इन्हीं क्लासेस में। तो क्लासेस मत मिस
करना। दूसरा सवाल आपका क्या है? व्हाट आर
द चांसेस इन जनरल आस्किंग टू गेट हैक्ड
यूजिंग दीज़ क्लाइंट अटैक्स? 100% चांसेस।
100% चांसेस अगर यह अटैक सक्सेस हुआ 100%
चांसेस मैं आपको टाइप्स ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग पढ़ाऊंगा ना तब देखना आपको
खुद ही पता चल जाएगा। एनीवन
किसी और कोई सवाल है मुझसे। चलो मैं आप
लोगों से एक रिव्यु ले रहा हूं। क्लास
कैसी लगी आज की?
स्लाइड्स अच्छी है।
मैं जो बोल रहा था और जो चीजें स्लाइड में
थी जो आपके विजुअल्स थे उनके साथ आप मैच
कर पा रहे थे। कोरिलेट कर पा रहे थे?
मैं जो बोल रहा था और जो स्लाइड थी उनके
साथ आप अपने आप कोरिलेट कर पा रहे थे। ऐसा
तो नहीं लगा कि सर स्लाइड में देख के
थोड़ा आपका सुनने में थोड़ा सा मुझे लग
रहा था कि आई एम फीलिंग बोर। ऐसा कुछ नहीं
था।
मजा आया सबको सेशन में
या शोर ऐसा करना पड़ेगा अरमान पटेल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
और किसी का कोई सवाल है? कोई मुझसे कुछ
पूछना चाहता है? एनीवन एनी क्वेश्चन
रिलेटेड टू द क्लास या किसी को क्या सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में सर हम जनरली हम क्या-क्या
सीखने वाले हैं? क्या है? मतलब कि किसी को
डाउट आ रहा है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास। प्लीज
पूछ लीजिए।
गुरुजी तो मेरे पुराने ओल्ड स्टूडेंट हैं।
किसी को कुछ पूछना है? दिस इज योर डाउट
सेशन।
डिस्कस कर सकते हो।
कंटेंट तो 45 टू 50 मिनट एनफ होता है। बट
मेरे नॉर्मली 45 मिनट्स का 1 आवर हो ही
जाता है।
हम
सोशल फिजिकल अटैक्स और फिजिकल एक्सेस और
अटैक्स भी आएंगे। नो ब्रो यह चीज आप भी
समझते हो कि
डेमोंस्ट्रेट करना बहुत ही
हो जाएगा क्योंकि फिजिकल एक्सेस आप मैं
आपको बस गाइडेंस कर दूंगा। हिंट दे दूंगा
बट वह आप लोगों को खुद ही करने पड़ेंगे।
इतना तो खुद करना पड़ेगा।
हां हां क्या था आपका क्वेश्चन बोलो
फाइनेंस कॉम आपका क्वेश्चन बोलो बोलो क्या
क्वेश्चन है
अभी पूछ लो मैं आपका शायद क्वेश्चन पिक अप
नहीं कर पाया पहले
यह सब आते हैं। फिजिकल अटैक्स भी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का पार्ट है। अरमान पटेल
मैंने पहले आपको बताया ना
भूल गए आप लोग सब सब लोग भूल गए।
एक बार दोबारा रीटाइप कर दो भाई।
कहां पे है आपका चैट?
क्लियर क्लियर क्लियर सर
व्हेन आई हैव लर्न योर वीडियोस आई लेट
पर्सनल लाइफ
सवाल नहीं समझा मैं आपका क्वेश्चन क्या है
प्लीज एक बार दोबारा पूछ लो
ओके मेरे पास 2022
डिप्लोमा है क्या सर्विस के बेस पर मुझे
शॉक में जॉब मिल सकती है क्या देखो आजकल
जॉब की तो रियलिटी यह है कि भाई
पता ही नहीं क्या होने वाला है। ठीक है
हां पता ही नहीं क्या होने वाला है बट
ट्राई कर सकते हो जैसे TCS हो गया या बहुत
सारी कंपनी है इनमें अभी
मैं आप लोगों एक चीज सलाह दूं। आपको एक
हिंट दूं आप लोग
हिंट यह है कि जो बिल्कुल स्टार्टअप कंपनी
है ना स्टार्टअप कंपनी
जैसे कि कोई भी अगर स्टार्टअप में है
कंपनी बिल्ड अप हो रही है जो अपनी आईफाई
आईटी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को अभी स्टार्टिंग
फेस से काम कर रहे हैं। ठीक है? उधर आपके
चांसेस ज्यादा हैं।
प्रॉब्लम क्योंकि मैं बहुत सारे मेरे
कलीग्स या बहुत सारे लोगों को जानता हूं।
देखो पहली बात तो आजकल इंडिया में तो पता
नहीं कंपनी में रिक्वायरमेंट ही अलग है।
सबको पता है। जॉब लगने को लग सकती है। ऐसी
कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है। बट रिक्वायरमेंट ही
अलग है। मैं तो ये बोलूंगा कि आपको जो
आपको फाइंड आउट करो या किसी अह किसी को
जानते हो तो स्टार्टअप कंपनी ना बिलकुल
स्टार्टअप कंपनी जो अह उनमें ट्राई करो।
स्टार्टअप कंपनियां क्या कर रही है ना कि
बट आपके पास एक्सपीरियंस है। डिप्लोमा
किया आपने एक्सपीरियंस नहीं है। मैं तो यह
बोलूंगा कि आपने कोई भी एक रोल पे
स्टार्टिंग में आपका कोई भी चाहे सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ही क्यों ना है एक उसको
एंटर कर लो।
ठीक है? उसमें एंटर कर लो। मैं क्योंकि
आजकल कंपनी क्या करती है कि आप नेटवर्क
में काम कर रहे थे पहले या सिस्टम एडमिन
काम कर रहे थे। फिर आपने प्रोफाइल स्विच
कर ली। आपकी इजी हो जाती है प्रोफाइल
स्विच करनी। आप डायरेक्टली जाते हो तो
डायरेक्टली
हार्डली उठा रहे हैं। उसके लिए इंटर्नशिप
होनी चाहिए या फिर इंटर्नशिप अपोरर्चुनिटी
भी मिल जाती है। बट टफ कंपटीशन बहुत
ज्यादा है। अभी क्योंकि बहुत लोग शॉक के
पीछे पड़े हैं। अभी क्या है आप सब ने पता
होगा कि नोटिस किया होगा कि शॉक डोमेन पे
बहुत ज्यादा पीछे पड़े हुए हैं। एआई आ गया
तो लोगों ऑफेंसिव साइड में तो एआई हैंडल
कर रहा है। बहुत सारे सॉफ्टवेयर आ रहे
हैं। तो एक काम करते हैं तो शॉक की तरफ
चले जाते हैं। तो लिटरली यह बात ऐसी कि
शॉक को थोड़े दिन में बट चीजें बदल रही
हैं। मेरे हिसाब से तो मुझे ऐसा लग रहा है
कि आने वाले एक या दो साल में डोमेन भी
चेंज हो जाएंगे। बहुत सारी चीजें चेंज हो
जाएंगी और क्योंकि बहुत सारी चीजें फास्ट
ट्रैक पे हैं। और आपके जो सिलेबस है
ग्रेजुएशन सिलेबस बदलने वाले हैं।
सिस्टम्स बदलने ही होंगे। अगर आप उनको हम
लोग नहीं बदलेंगे या गवर्नमेंट उनको नहीं
बदलेगी या कोई उन्शन नहीं लेगा तो जॉब
नहीं मिल पाएगी। हार्ड ट्रुथ है यह।
बट मैं यह बोल रहा हूं कि आपको
कहीं पर भी ज्वाइन कर लो एक बार किसी भी
कंपनी में उसके बाद कैरियर स्विच करना
बहुत आसान हो जाएगा।
उसके बाद करियर स्विच करना बहुत आसान हो
जाएगा। चाहे आप इवन ही कोई नॉर्मल आप
डेस्कटॉप इंजीनियर क्यों ना जाओ या आप
एडमिशन इंजीनियर ही क्यों ना जाओ या फिर
एक नॉर्मल कोई भी या फिर बोला कि मुझे मैं
कर लूंगा काम तो बिल्कुल ठीक है तो वो
सारी चीजें
अब मायने रखती है बस एक बार ज्वाइन करोगे
उसमें आपको इजी हो जाएगा
बहुत मुश्किल हो गया आजकल सच बात देखो
आपको घुमाने का तो क्या फायदा है? Lindin
पे बहुत सारी है। बट किसी का भी देखो आप
Lindin पे उठा के। सबका क्या है कि इतना
एक्सपीरियंस होना चाहिए। सबको एक्सपीरियंस
वाले चाहिए। तो फिर अभी नए नए जो
स्टूडेंट्स हैं वो सिखाएगा कौन? सोचने की
बात है ना भाई। इसमें सिखाएगा कौन? सबको
एक्सपीरियंस बंदे एक्सपीरियंस होल्डर
चाहिए। तो कोई तो सिखाने के लिए चाहिए।
एंड उनका भी रिप्लेसमेंट चाहिए।
रिप्लेसमेंट कौन बनाएगा?
सब क्या पीछे पड़े हुए हैं। बस हमारी
कंपनी बड़ी हो जाए, बड़ी हो जाए। बट
रिप्लेसमेंट के लिए बारे में ज्यादा सोच
ही नहीं रहे।
क्योंकि यार बात ऐसी है आजकल
पता नहीं क्या होने वाला है। मैं तो वही
सोच रहा हूं कि अभी मैं क्या करियर
रिलेटेड जैसे कि ये बातें होती है कि सर
मैं अभी ऑफेंसिव साइड में नौकरी लग जाएगी
या शोक एनलिस्ट साइड में नौकरी लग जाएगी।
मैं तो यही बोलता हूं कि भाई अभी स्किल
सीख लो जितनी सीखनी हो थोड़ा वेट करो।
चीजें बदल रही हैं। कुछ लोग फायर हो रहे
हैं, कुछ लोग इन हो रहे हैं। बस फोकस करो
कि चल क्या रहा है।
फोकस करो चल क्या रहा है दुनिया में? उसके
हिसाब से अपने आप को अपग्रेड करते रहो।
फिर राइट टाइम राइट प्लेस एंटर कर जाओ।
मैं यही बोल रहा हूं। राइट टाइम का वेट
करो क्योंकि पता नहीं कितने डोमेन कितनी
सारी चीजें बदल बदल रही है धीरे-धीरे
ज्यादा टाइम नहीं लगेगा विद इन वन या टू
इयर्स में चीजें बहुत बदल जाएंगी बहुत
ज्यादा बहुत सारी चीजें वैकेंसीज
रिक्वायरमेंट बहुत कुछ बदलने वाला है हां
ऑब्जर्व द टाइम ऑब्जर्व द प्लेसेस और किसी
को अगर अच्छे
किसी कंपनी में करने वाले को जानते हो तब
तक के लिए तो उनके साथ गाइडेंस लो उनसे
थोड़ा सा और मिलो उनके साथ बैठो क्योंकि
उनके पास ज्यादा इंटरनल न्यूज़ होती हैं।
किसी भी किसी को भी जानते हो चाहे आप अपने
रिलेशनशिप में जानते हो या किसी भी कहीं
पर भी जानते हो फ्रेंड सर्कल है फ्रेंड का
फ्रेंड का फ्रेंड का फ्रेंड सर्कल है तो
देन बातें करने की कोशिश करो।
हां बिल्कुल
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। बातें तो
करते रहेंगे तो
कुछ नहीं है तो
सेशन को एंड करें। अगर कोई सवाल नहीं है
तो फिर आप लोगों का
क्योंकि अगर मैं आपके सवाल का जवाब यही दे
देता कि नहीं भाई 100% मिल जाएगी वह मिल
जाएगी। उसका कोई फायदा नहीं था। मैं आपको
झूठ बोल के
क्या फायदा होता मेरे को? कुछ फायदा नहीं
होता।
आपको मैं झूठ बोलता, आपको फालतू की दिलाशा
दिलाता। उसका कोई फायदा नहीं था।
थोड़ा सा एक बार बुरा लगे सामने वाले को
सच बोल दो उससे बेटर रहता है रेदर देन
आपको उसको करने के लिए 101 चीजें आपको वो
है विजुअलाइज करनी पड़ेंगी बताना पड़ेगा
वो करना पड़ेगा उसको करना पड़ेगा नो नो
सीधा साफ सच बोलो बस
यार मैंने काफी टाइम से gtए को ऑन भी नहीं
किया मेरे
चलिए फिर बाय बाय गुड नाइट एवरीवन
अमन का क्या क्वेश्चन रह गया?
यह क्या बोल रहा है सर? वन क्लिक में कुछ
भी हैक हो जाता है। लोग बोलते हैं तो यह
हैक नहीं कर कर सकता। तो कहां से हैकर?
देखो यार अरमान पटेल लोगों की बातों पे
ध्यान नहीं देना चाहिए। सीधी सी बात है।
उन्होंने खुद तो कुछ जिंदगी में किया नहीं
होता। कुछ नहीं उखाड़ा होता उन्होंने अपनी
जिंदगी में। ठीक है? खुद कुछ पता नहीं
होता होगा। ठीक है? खुद जो तुम्हें नॉलेज
होगी जो चीज तुम्हें पता भी होगी ना जितना
तुम्हें करना होता उसको उसके बारे में कुछ
नहीं पता होगा उनको बस क्या होता है ना
मोटिवेट करना आता नहीं उनके पास एक ही
ऑप्शन है डीमोटिवेट कर लेते हैं ठीक है
उसको क्या पता कि हैकिंग के टर्म का ही
मतलब नहीं पता होगा उसको हैकिंग होती क्या
हैकिंग का एक्चुअल मतलब क्या होता हैकर्स
क्या करते हैं उनके सब आज भी 2026 में
लोगों को हैकिंग वर्ड का मतलब यही समझ में
आता है कि वो एक क्लिक किया मूवी में जैसे
हुआ और वो हो हो गया। सब कुछ अंडर
कंप्रोमाइज हो गया। बस उस रियलिटी को कौन
बताएगा? वह एक क्लिक जिस क्लिक की बात कर
रहे हो कि एक क्लिक किया हैक हो गया। सब
कुछ कंट्रोल हो गया। उस क्लिक के लिए
कितना वर्कआउट, कितनी मेहनत, कितनी सालों
साल उस चीज को फाइंड आउट किया जाता है उस
लूप होल को और राइट टाइम का वेट किया जाता
है उस क्लिक का। नोबडी टॉक अबाउट इट। उसके
बारे में कोई बात नहीं करेगा।
ठीक है? वह पूरा सेटअप कैसे किया जाता है?
एग्जैक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन होना,
एग्जैक्ट टाइम पर सही टाइम का वेट करना और
टाइम आगे पीछे हो गया तो
समझ रहे हो? लोगों की बात में नहीं जाना
देना चाहिए। भाई आप सीखो वन क्लिक पे होता
है नहीं होता उससे उसको मतलब नहीं होना
चाहिए। बोला आपको लगता है लगने दो। पर
अपने आप को हैकर क्यों बताते हो यार?
पता नहीं अपने आप को बताओ कि मैं
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर हूं। सिक्योरिटी
टेस्टर्स हूं। सिक्योरिटी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट हूं। जब आपको सारे
डोमेन की नॉलेज हो जाए।
यह अच्छा है। लोग आपको जज तो नहीं करेंगे।
नो प्रॉब्लम।
कॉल कर लो यार। मेरा फोन नंबर कौन सा
वीआईपी का फोन नंबर है?
जो पता भी चल जाएगा तो क्या होगा? मेरे
पास ब्लॉक का ऑप्शन है। परेशान करोगे तो
ब्लॉक कर दूंगा। कितने नंबर कॉल करोगे?
ठीक है। नो प्रॉब्लम। टीचर हूं यार,
इंस्ट्रक्टर हूं। आपका ट्रेनर हूं तो किसी
के पास मेरा नंबर भी होगा। तो क्या कर
लोगे? बात ही तो करोगे ना। गाइडेंस लोगे
नहीं फर्क पड़ता भाई।
तो मुझे प्रोटेक्ट करना आता है। अपने आप
को भी आता है। सोच समझ सब चीजें आती हैं।
मेरा काम है आपको एक अच्छा बेस्ट ट्रेनिंग
प्रोवाइड करना। आपको एक अच्छा इंसान
बनाना। आपको गलत चीजों में जाने से रोकना।
चलिए फिर बाद में बात करेंगे। ओके बाय-ब
एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन। एंड
बाय-ब सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन। कल सेशन
में मिलते हैं। कंटिन्यू करते हैं। ओके।